the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
adoring fan 's packed the playing Hall
at the superbet chess classic in
Bucharest Romania after a drawn round
Rife with missed opportunities players
were ready for decisive results Anish
giri got his first win taking down ding
laryn with a vicious kingside attack
that left the world champion reeling all
the Reza farugia continued his Stellar
play defeating janapo miyachi to
catapult into the co lead there's a tie
at the top with two rounds to go day
eight of amazing chess coming up next
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back everybody to day 8 of the
2023 Superbad chess Classic held here in
beautiful Bucharest Romania has been a
fantastic event so far filled with
trails and Spills but right now we are
entering the championship rounds and the
players will have to give us everything
they have over the chessboard let's go
to the studio in St Louis and start the
action for day eight
we welcome you to the first step on the
2023 grandchild store and our coverage
of superbed Romania we come to you live
from the Saint Louis chess club
foreign
thanks for joining our show I'm
International Master nazify kids and I'm
here with Grandmaster
yesi as always great to see you in the
morning they said you were a rookie you
were a seasoned professional your
presentation's been wonderful it's great
to work with you thank you so much
absolutely hello everyone and welcome to
the championship rounds we've got two to
play rounds eight and nine and it is
jam-packed at the top quite a number of
players could potentially win the event
tell us about the standings Nasi right
let's see honors let's take a look we
have two co-leaders Fabiano caruana and
aliriza fieruja with four and a half
points look at that chasing pack right
very closely following Wesley so Anish
giri and Richard rapper stand at 50 if
he can do something today and tomorrow
our defending Champion yes Maxine
rachiela Graf uh with three points young
Christoph Duda and with 2.5
that tie for eighth and 9th I just look
at that and say somebody has made a typo
and tell us about the format
the format is 10 player round robin with
classical time control 90 minutes for
the first 40 moves 30 minutes for the
rest of the game and 30 second increment
from move one right and players are not
allowed to offer any drugs they have a
regular scoring system with one point
for a win half for a draw and zero for a
loss not much left but tell us about the
schedule
right we have two more rounds to go the
players will be playing round eight
today and tomorrow will be the final
round which will start one hour early in
case of a tie just remind everybody what
would happen in the playoffs
we'll have a tie breaks in case of a tie
so if it's a two players type that will
have a two game rapid match with 15
minutes with 10 second increment for
each move mate got it in case three
players type at first then there will be
a rapid round robin with 10 minutes and
5 Second increment a little bit faster
still tied Armageddon with five minutes
for white four minutes for black and a
two second increment from move 61.
terrible on the nerves of the player has
been excited for the fans there's
Armageddon and as always we're delighted
to have in studio bar good to see you my
friend uh tell us about the road ahead
for the potential winners of the event
thank you guys and yeah it's uh we have
two very exciting rounds remaining we
have five players at the top I think one
of these five players will win the
tournament we have alireza and Fabiano
have a point ahead but the three other
players are in conditions so let's take
a look here so this is the standing here
with the top five trying to fight for
the first place here I think one of them
will be the winner we could see a
possible tie break so let's take a road
ahead for richer report here so he's
facing his friend who you work for and
help him to become world champion
dingler and then last round big game
against Fabiano caruana
Wesley saw he's facing iyanya promise
who's been struggling perhaps a chance
there and also Duda he he has a you know
a little bit easier road ahead in the
last two rounds I think
then then we have anishkiri who is
coming off a very nice win in a previous
round he's a has a big game against
Fabiano caruana and last round he's
playing Yanni polmanship
and now the co-leader firuja on plus two
after his win from yesterday he's
playing Duda and last round his
countryman mvl
and Fabiano who's been leading the
tournament for many of the rounds he's
playing Anish as I mentioned and last
round he's got a top hit against Richard
reports so his road ahead looks very
very tough guys and we're gonna go to
Romania to our friend Grandmaster
Christian chirilla
thanks Warren welcome back chess fans to
day 8 here in Bucharest Romania this is
it we are entering the championship
rounds of the 2023 Superbad chess
classic we've had an amazing tournament
so far and a lot of the chess has been
extremely extremely Fighting Chess and
let's take a look at the percentage of
um decisive results in this competition
we see six wins for the white pieces
four wins for the black pieces with 25
draws that's a 28.6 percent and let's
not forget a couple of days ago we had
five draws in that round but even those
drawers were extremely fighting who said
classical chess is not Fighting Chess
almost one in three games have been
decisive results just an incredible
accomplishment for these players who
came here to Bucharest to fight and
speaking of Fighting Chess we have a big
Clash on our hands today of course I'm
talking about the game between uh the
leader Fabiano caruana one of the
co-leaders of the event against a very
In-Shape Anish aguiri who just defeated
the world champion dingley ran yesterday
with the white pieces impeccable opening
preparation and a well-timed sacrifice
on a G5 got the job done for Anish but
today with the black pieces well if he
wants to catch up with Fabiano he
potentially might be looking at a well
he wants to get a victory and the same
can be said for Fabiano caruana who
right now is in the cold lead position
with one Ali brezza firuja who is
definitely hot hot hot right now just an
incredible sequence for the youngster he
won two of his last three games and
right now he is in the co-leading
position so definitely Fabi with the
white pieces this is the last time in
this event that he will be having the
white pieces he's definitely looking to
strike big big clash between these two
players another one that I'm having my
eyes on and as you can see right now
Fabiano with Anish getting ready to
start this incredible matchup I don't
know what you guys expect but I'm
expecting fireworks in that one this is
another big lash I'm having my eyes on
not a lot of people have been speaking
about mvl but he's on 50 one point
behind the leader and with a victory
today with a white piece against Bogdan
Daniel that he will inch closer to those
co-leading positions and as we have seen
on that graphic as well he has revenge
on his mind because in last year's
iteration of the Superbad chess classic
he lost against Bogdan Daniel that in
their only encounter In classical or
Rapid or blitz so definitely mvl very
focused and ready to take on the
Romanian Prodigy guys we have so many
exciting games on our hands in day eight
here from Bucharest Romania thank you
Christian and for those key matchups but
Nasi uh laid the table for our audience
and tell them about the pairings for all
the players all right let's take a look
at today's match perhaps we have mvl
playing Duck Right a new world champion
Dean playing his second return yeah
Richard that'll be interesting to watch
Carolina against Gary a lot of marbles
in that game the Palm Beach against
Wesley cell and finally our co-leader
Duda against firoza all right very nice
a lot of fighting fighting games but
what are they fighting for right they
are fighting for a big prize fund total
uh prices uh 350 000 and the first place
winner is going to get one hundred
thousand dollars second place 65 000 30
48 000. in a very very handsome prizes
all the way down the 10th and last place
grantchester points up for grabs you win
clear first you get a bonus one
grandchester points you'll get 13. tie
for first and you chop up the price the
grandchild stores and this is Victor
bolagon uh Victor of course an
international Grandmaster works at the
fida's office and I haven't seen him in
ages but still knows how to move the
pieces
and uh our executive director of the
feedback in fact I'll stand corrected on
that one Victor he had uh he had quite a
reputation for being a sharp sharp he
was number one for his country for many
years exactly he worked very closely
with the Lexi shiroff training with
Alexi in much of his career as we see
again this huge match between
um Bobby and Anish now I remember VAR
specifically a candidates tournament it
got down to the very end and there was
Fabi versus on each but let me stop
myself for a second we have another
ceremonial first move
yes
yeah the president of the Romanian Chess
Federation I think
yes I just forgot his name
so his presence here is well deserved
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
okay this is the big moment don't blow
it
yes sir E2 E4
King pawns opening as Bobby Fischer said
Best Buy test
all the players for understanding these
few moments of start and thank you to
all the guests and all the people in
Ethiopians
just remind ourselves that MBL is the
defending champion of the super bad
chess classic from last year and
although he's had a very uneven event
one way of saying not successful he can
turn things around with abrasive wins
he's got to he's got the white pieces
he's facing the lowest rated player in
the field he's got to put it together if
you want wants to fight for the first
place can you still win today exactly
and as I was saying bar I remember a
candidates tournament where it was one
of the last rounds uh ultimate rounds
like rounds 12 13-14 and Bobby had the
white pieces against
Anish played one E4 they got into an
open Sicilian and Anish comprehensively
outplayed Fabi won the game and
destroyed Bobby's chances of becoming
Challenger
yes I remember and also once in another
campaign tournament earlier Fabiano
escaped in a groom fell down something
like four ponds I think it was in Moscow
2016 and Anisha has been a tough
opponent and Fabi mentioned that
yesterday in the interview the score is
very equal and an issue is very well
prepared that players you know his
openings are extremely strong but once
again to reflect their head to head when
you said even this is you meant it you
know what happens when two very solid
players play each other yeah three wins
three losses 29 draws they know each
other
very very well indeed that's that's
quite a number of games between the two
of them and nothing between them I mean
it's just so so close
um you kind of dig a Little Deeper there
uh we I just mentioned the game that
Fabi lost with the white pieces that was
so so uh key is it I want to say are we
going to see E4 and potentially an open
Sicilian
solid e45 E4 E5 for me when I see Anish
playing E5 I see him coming into the
game saying I want to play solid C5
would have been shown a great deal of
ambition in my opinion Bishop C4 uh
Italian game and you know how ironic
that Anish Gary just won a game against
the world champion in the Italian as
white right and I think maybe the game
at the tournament maybe a career rear
defining game for Anisha himself I was
so impressed by his victory yesterday
yeah
see a repeat of that game no
and at night F6 so the two nights
defends and today I mean I think
everybody's playing D3 they don't sa
Knight G5 so D3 Bishop C5
I think Fabi has a lot of very nice wins
in this opening oh my gosh I mean it's a
spaghetti uh the number of games have
just exploded
and just to make a a quick comparison uh
if
D7 D6 is played Right Here Right Now by
Anish Gary it will be a mirror of the
game that's going on between MBL and
dioc and it's it's funny the the
Gothenburg variation of the Sicilian
night orph
so the the idea was there was an
interzonal tournament taking place in
Sweden and the three Argentine Grand
Masters were playing against the three
Soviet Grandmasters and they all the
argentinians played the same defense
that they had prepared in their training
and the Soviet players realized that
playing all the same position and they
stopped and they waited for Geller effen
Geller to play the move and then they
all repeated what Galler played
D7 D6 so
um
watch the strongest players
and by the way we do have a Berlin on
the board in uh the game between nepo
and Wesley and this is uh one of the
many
ways a famous drawing lines
who has the most number of draws in this
particular position they're uh uh VAR
because when players with the white
pieces want to make a draw this is how
they play right absolutely yeah there
are a lot of games by Hikaru and a lot
of other top players has a game so the
Knight takes B5 this is how usually they
make a drill here yeah and we've got the
uh head-to-head classical games by the
way I mean Wesley so what a performance
six wins for Wesley that's huge one one
win for Nepal but six draws so Wesley
really owns uh nepo I mean maybe that's
another reason why Yan chose this
opening today probably so you were about
to tell us uh uh VAR that this is the
way uh Nakamura amongst others have
played absolutely many many draws in
this lines in this line I will show you
so the point is you take only five and a
knight takes B5
and then white plays the move A4
attacking the Knight on B5 which is
trapped yeah Knight is trapped right now
so you play Knight bd4
Knight takes D4
and here's a 1964
Queen D4 now you play D5
and
it takes D6 Queen takes D6 and we see
this repetition with Queen E4 because
you cannot develop the bishop because B7
Pawn is hanging and if you put the
bishop only seven you're pinned after
rookie one there is also Bishop before
so we see many many games and in a draw
here a lot of a lot of top players so I
expect to see something like this to
happen because Ian chose this drawish
line
and let's just jump to Bucharest with a
Christian and a special guest
thanks yes we are with Victor bologna
the executive director of Fida Victor
first of all welcome back to our show
you've been here in Romania last year as
well what are your first impressions of
the organizations here yeah thanks
thanks uh for welcoming back and it's
always a pleasure and an honor to be at
this tournament it's one of the biggest
and most important tournament in the
world uh it's always good to be here I
like very much I think it's a bit
different setup this year it's more
Spectators which I always like when I
played myself on the stage when you have
spectators you play better and because
you your work is appreciated so that's
what I see the first difference because
I just arrived this morning but
otherwise playing Hall is completely
packed yeah yeah but yeah okay it's
Sunday today but also it's uh it's a
clear evidence that the tournament is
getting more and more recognition and
the interest from the local public it's
also important not to have only online
which definitely the numbers are growing
going up but also in physical presence
so that's what I like but in general of
course it's always on the highest level
possible the company the organizers
super bad they are doing very good job
and together with the Romanian chest
Federation so it's all pleasure
especially we had today already feed the
technical meeting today so it's more
more events coming in yeah that's great
and speaking of the biggest events that
you just mentioned we just had the
concluded world championship match
between uh Ding and Jan how did you
leave that from inside the organization
yeah I had the privilege to be on the
beginning of the match and definitely
again it was organized very well
and that I think this was the most
combative match out of if we compare
with all these draws in this Carlson
karaoke in Carolina Carlson matches of
course it was more interesting maybe
more mistakes but it was very
entertaining and okay this was dramatic
the final but definitely even an absence
of the form world champion Magnus
Carlson the match was very interesting
to watch and I'm happy to see both
participants here in Bucharest of course
it's very tiring for them to play here
after such they gave everything they had
all their energy knowledge and but it's
it's good to see them here and I think
that was a very well organized match and
it was a success speak a bit about that
what do they have to do to get their
energy back because you've been a
competitor at the highest level as well
how difficult it is to come back with
fresh ideas fresh energy after such it's
not it's not about ideas because usually
if you prepare for a world championship
match then the idea is prepared for a
Machi it can serve you for another year
unless we know this week of ideas from
doing site but okay that's another story
it's more about definitely energy
motivation and but all by old style by
all the fashion you would never play a
tournament in the next few months but
now we know that the calendar is very
tight which is much more popular they're
very important competition and of course
grantchester is not only one competition
it's a series of competitions and that's
why I think the players committed to to
play here I don't envy them you know
it's really a very big change and
practically it's by default that they
will be under their normal level to
participate here so but how to recover
of course you have to sleep you have to
get some fresh air so but this I don't
think it's the case for them because I
know for after a difficult game after a
difficult tournament the quality of
sleep is much worse so it's only
challenges I mean I I don't have a good
good recipe for them yeah well you guys
at fide are bringing a lot of
competitions here in Romania there is
one coming up in July the internet
National School stress Festival tell us
a bit about that I would say opposite
actually we have some feed has some good
partners and Romanian just federations
in one of them like kazakhstan's
Federation for example we had this the
world championship match there and we
have the world Blitzen rocket there same
in Romania we have we organizes
granchester story organized many youth
events and the initiative about this
tournament in place right by the way my
grandfather used to live all his life
and players
so so the initiative came of course from
the Romanian side and jonus the
pronunciano he he he will be he's
already the new the chairperson of this
organizations chess and school
organization so the initiative comes
from municipality from him from the
government and Via support we just
endorse it but it's very good moment for
this tournament to be organized because
the idea of the promoting of
inter-school competitions on the World
level on the global level uh it's
something new uh we had this tradition
and if you remember in Romania and
former Soviet Union and other countries
when we have the Center School
competitions now we bring it to the
level of global competition and after
immediately after that next month we
will organize also the world school
championship so this tournament this
Festival in place will be a very
important stage like repetition before
the championship and for me my first
game I won in my career it was in this
inter-school competition so I really
think it's very important competition
and we are thankful to the Romanian
organizers for this initiative it's
always a pleasure to hear that more and
more youth competitions and the new
generation is being nurtured here in
Romania Victor thank you very much for
joining the show and we'll see you
around thank you so much thank you thank
you
guys back to you and thank you for that
Christian indeed do you still remember
your Scholastics competitions as we see
nepo Wesley Racing for drawn this the
eighth uh
round uh Championship round but nepo I
mean I think he just wants to put this
tournament behind him and we're about to
see a repetition back and forth Queen D6
Queen e for check quite a number what we
might call Grand Master draws but again
nepo's competition
hasn't gone his way not at all not at
all and he put this one behind him
Wesley on the other hand he has had I
want to say a nice event yes but
multiple chances I would say to also
improve his score and he is he's just
there I think he's kind of showboating a
bit we're going to see a draw another
game I always found it very difficult to
play against players I worked with in
other words trainer games if you will
and the game between dingler in and
Richie Rapport nothing exceptional there
I think these two gentlemen they really
appreciate respect what happened in the
world championship
that was quite the adventure for both of
them and here they're facing off now
Richie is the one having a very
successful event he might be thinking
you know well my guy is a little bit
tired I should like to fight and play
but even a wounded world champion
Champion still a world world champion
and the draw has been agreed between
nepo and Wesley I don't think Wesley
mines a drill with black pieces Quick
Draw he gets to rest today and come back
tomorrow I think he has white pieces
exactly for the final round so
it's always a little bit you know for
the spectators you know you see see the
the rounds barely underway and you've
already made a draw but again uh this
jockey for Grand chest tour positioning
grantchester points and the prize fund
um
both players essentially
happy with the result VAR jump in and
tell us
what games have caught your attention
yeah let's take a look at one of the
games do that game is very interesting
it's actually one of the openings that I
played for many years it's a slav
exchange so I have some knowledge about
that opening so I will show you some key
lines there
so he is playing fioruja here so it's a
slav defense exchange variation
so and uh
so we I'll get to the key position here
and this was played actually in a world
championship match in 2008 between
kramnik and Anand yeah this particular
line and here after the move Bishop
before white also has this interesting
option 95 which is also quite popular
here but he played the move Bishop B5
which I played uh many many times you
actually have a threat you just want to
take Queen takes B4 here pick up the
bishop and actually won a game once in a
simul one of my uh you know young
students played the move Queen B6 here
thinking that if I take on C6 he takes
back with a pawn and the bishop is
protected but he didn't realize that
actually I can just take the bishop here
immediately and you cannot capture back
because of the pin here in fact this
position Queen B3 is very tricky move
you really have to know the theory here
otherwise you can lose here immediately
for example B6 will lose to the move
Bishop B5 immediately and you don't have
a good way to protect C6 and 95 is
winning a piece another option is if you
play Queen D7 same thing Queen is very
badly placed here you play the move 95
attacking the queen if you take back
Pawn takes attacking the Knight and as
soon as the Knight moves you lose your
queen to the move Bishop B5 whoops again
yeah and that's why you really have to
play the move Bishop before uh I think
there was a game between uh evanchuk and
Hikaru after the move Queen B6 they got
to a similar structure maybe with a
different move order anyone took one
excellent game in this end game because
of just these two weaknesses it's
actually a very unpleasant endgame to
play you always have to worry about this
pawns here but in the game we see the
move Bishop B4 which is the best move
Bishop B5
now castles Bishop C6 and of course you
cannot capture back the bishop
immediately you lose the bishop so you
have to play Bishop C3 Queen takes C3
and and here's a black is alireza is
still taking Rook C8 is by far the most
popular move but I hit a game like this
against Grandmaster book Synergy from
China in 2019 he actually took back
which was a little bit of a surprise for
me I always thought after this I should
be a little bit better but it's not so
clear even here there's some Dynamics
with the move Knight E4 here coming up
but the main move from that mentioned
game Anand uh kramnik Anand was Rook
Rook C8 Knight E5
Knight G4
and now after capture here is a very
important move you have to play as white
otherwise after Rook C6 you have
absolutely nothing you have to play the
move Queen before
and here if you take back with the pawn
this position is actually quite
unpleasant because you have just two
really serious weaknesses A7 and C6 and
white has a long-term Advantage here so
that's why you have to play the move
Rooks C6 Queen takes B7 Queen C8 takes
and with a very accurate play actually
black should be able to hold this end
game but there are some important moves
you have to know
and once again the head-to-head uh
lifetime score between these two uh
players due to Perugia okay it looks
pretty one-sided doesn't it I gotta tell
you we have four wins against student
three draws not bad and if Ali could
pull off a victory today wouldn't that
be sweet as that would Propel him into
first place talking about first place I
just want to turn our attention back to
the game of Bobby for a moment because
from uh the Italian opening I want to
say that Fabi is played as ambitiously
as he possibly could so we don't see
this a lot after D7 D6 white undertakes
the immediate expansion before
oftentimes we see in these Italian games
that black is playing moves like Asics
as well as A5 in preparation for this
expansion well Fabi does it right away
B4 A4 let's go now your Bishop's about
to be trapped I mean you've got to pay
attention to this threat but anisha's
move A5 not only addresses the threat it
introduces one of his own he's ready to
capture twice on B4 thank you for the
pawn now after you push the Knight away
I've often said the night on C6 is a bit
of a problem piece in the E5 E4 E5
Construction
is very happy to get in the maneuver
Knight C6 to E7 to G6 his Knight's going
to be fine on G6 helping his King blah
blah blah everything's going well now
after Castle's 97 I have seen so often
players play Preparatory moves like age
to age three rookie one and slowly
slowly slowly unwind I've also seen
Bishop B3 or Bishop A2 Bishop B3 Bishop
A2 making room for the Knights of the
night can swing itself to see for Menace
the bishop but I tell you it's very rare
to see why you know like a little like
bang going uh D3 D4 so white has gotten
in his Queen side expansion very early
he's expanding in the center I mean I
can see it's still all Theory but
I can't imagine White playing any more
ambitiously than Fabi is right now VAR
absolutely yeah he he actually played
this D4 movie it's a pretty rare move
here guys it's only seven games played
the main move in this position is Bishop
B3 instead so in this position has been
played I I see 173 games in my database
here and the main move is Bishop B3 also
perhaps with idea Knight C4 attacking
the bishop and then you can play Bishop
E3 and recapture with it now you really
want to have a knight only three in this
position to be able to jump into D5 and
have five squares so Bishop B3 is the
main move rookie one is played 25 games
Bishop A2 as well with the same idea to
clear the C4 square but this move d4 is
uh pretty rare here and I'm looking at
the names I don't see any big names that
play this most so this is definitely
some good prep here by Fabiano and in
all seven games played in this position
black played the move Bishop G4 which
which is also the best move recommended
by the engines and the idea here is
you're already threatening to take care
on F3 so for example if H3 then you have
Bishop takes F3 and if you take back
with the queen I can take the pawn on D4
and recapture with the bishop and if you
take with the Knight now you have the E4
Pawn hanging so that's why you have to
do something after the move Bishop G4
and the best move here is to play Queen
C2 you get out get out of the pin and at
the same time now if the capture is on
after you take back with this Knight and
E4 Pawn is protected so after the move
Queen C2 black can just continue
developing with the queen D7 now
connecting the Rooks and getting ready
to put the Rook on E8 and perhaps the
other Rook on D1 so it's it's an equal
position and uh there are a few more
moves I can show here D takes E5 if it
pawn takes E5 Bishop A3 and you play
Rook fd8
and it looks like it's a quality but it
can get really sharp there is a
possibility of the move Knight G5 here
as well
thank you uh bar and once again the
lifetime result we highlighted this in
the road ahead three to three and 29
draws was it conveying exactly wow
nothing between them uh by the way we
have one other game that is also racing
to a draw and that's the game we
referenced earlier between ding lyrin
who is having Frankly Speaking a really
tragic tournament for the new world
champion I'm sure he gained ambitiously
to this event just not aware or getting
a good sense of his own energy levels
and by the way you know you really don't
know
until you get there I mean exactly there
are certain times that you feel really
really well and everything has gone
wrong for our newly crowned world
champion and he
I think is heading uh quickly for a draw
and this queen and Knight versus queen
and Knight position and if we can take
three the ldx game started exactly the
same as Carolina giris but then mvl
chose to develop Knight to A3 instead of
D2 which is more typical way to develop
exactly he played castles there was no
b2b4 and a2a4 as in the game of Abby
ecass also a7a5 very traditional move
just to stop the move b4bit in some ways
you know you you're ready to sidestep uh
a d3d4 so as you were saying the Knight
did not go to the traditional D2 square
but rather the A3 squares it's not that
you're really menacing the move Knight
B5 I think it's just a different pathway
into the center of the board see I'm not
familiar with Italian game I don't
really play E4 E5 it's a knight c2's
idea to go to E3 or is it supporting D4
uh to go to E3 and oftentimes it depends
in some ways it's like an echo of
yesterday's game white is waiting for
black to play castle so you can go
Bishop G5 right you know and Anisha
might have trouble playing the H6 G5 uh
to break the pin right so it definitely
you would love to have your Bishop on G5
and the Knight on the E3 Square so that
you could Menace Knight D4 the active
play H6 to avoid yeah uh something that
maybe Dean later in where she had done
also is uh it's it's a a cautious move
but we know why after studying the game
of Anish yesterday why the move H7 H6
that precaution is sometimes married at
night C2 castles Bishop E3 this is kind
of a success Smalls you but you like the
small victory right they add up right so
it's a kind of a small success that this
bishop on A7 does get to trade itself to
for its counterpart
and again the same night maneuver as as
Daniel looks to re uh route his night
he's not particularly worried about
Bishop takes E7 Rook takes A7 fun fact I
send the leeches database that there is
one game played by bhakta and Danielle
diak with black pieces yeah yes so uh
the mvl could have prepared this
position how did it go uh those Bishop
takes A7 okay Rook takes A7 and D4 and
D3 D4 right away okay intriguing d3d and
uh Danielle did win this game with a
black piece with the black pieces and
how did it continue if you don't mind me
asking 9g6 Knight G6 DTX E5 Pawn takes
back and the Queen's guide Exchange
Trade trade and Rook a to D1 and then
black went on to win a very equal
looking ending I don't assume I assume
he played rookie I don't see trade he
traded and even though this Rook looks a
little forlorn you can see that c6b5 or
The Rook would just drop back so equal
position so he's got experience in this
ending now one of the things that I
always worry about is white in such
positions after we trade trade and D3 D4
I always worry about okay I can take
play night take
um part sorry I can take and play for
the move at D5 so the highly desirable
you know keep your Central Pawn Duo be
very nicely is met by D5 and that breaks
up the team really reduces whites
Advantage with an isolated Bond that's
not exactly what uh not with the Knight
on C2 you know no no no so uh but of
course in this particular moment you
would probably recapture the queen
uh may be provoking Knight C6 and why
well it's not much it's not much but
probably I would prefer to play White
let's just drop in on the game between
dingler and versus his trainer Richie
report because they have been a
repetition yes they just shook him hands
and agreed to intro yes as Dean lerin
hopes to wind down arguably one of the
worst tournaments of his career yes
unfortunately for him but Richard gets
to have a little bit of a rest day today
as well as Wesley tomorrow he's going to
be playing the tournament leader Fabiano
with the white pieces right and you
couldn't ask for anything better than
that Destinies in your hands
he'll have some extra time today to
prepare against Bobby yeah so
Championship rounds uh today and
tomorrow as uh well at the start of the
show uh VAR you were saying the road
ahead to the players and as we were
doing those comparisons of the roads
ahead it seemed to me that Fabi had the
hardest road to hoe as he's playing all
of his nearest Rivals absolutely Yasser
he's playing Anish who is in good form
and definitely motivated after
yesterday's beautiful Victory against
the world champion and then he's playing
a report and he needs to be careful you
know if he takes too much risks and
perhaps lose a game then report can
actually surpass him and uh so it's very
important game here for fabianote
against Anish and uh yeah once again the
road ahead this is for Anish he's
playing Fabiano and then he's playing
Ayan with the white pieces I see an
opportunity in that game because
definitely Jan is struggling and he just
wants this tournament to finish as soon
as possible so I see a game where Anish
is definitely gonna press so even if
he's half a point behind let's say he
draws today it's a good result he still
has opportunities to win tomorrow and
perhaps Force the tie break
and this is a crucial game if you update
us on the game between Fabi and Anish
because we had just a few moves that
were played again I wanted to say that
from Bobby's point of view he has played
the most ambitious way he could he's
expanded both on the queen side and as
well as with the move D3 D4 in the
center H7 H6 were still in the computer
database of openings rookie one rookie
eight Bishop A3 that's a little bit off
the Beaten Track and if I can
pick your database for a moment what is
the outcome
percentage-wise in this position barred
as white win often black went often draw
what what what what what what are the
stats well we have only one game yeah
sir and that's one game ended in a draw
here I think black is very comfortable
here in this position I see some good
opportunities for him so let's take a
look at some of the key uh ideas here in
this position for both players sure so
that one game played between I think two
grand Masters about 2600 and here's
black can actually start off with with a
pretty aggressive looking move Knight F4
here it's it's not that necessary to
develop the bishop on G4 immediately so
just Knight comes into F4 and uh the
best move is to try to bring this bishop
back on F1 here at some point you're
gonna you're gonna try to maybe play the
move G3 to remove this knight uh because
if let's say you don't want to do that
you play the move Queen C2 just
developing then there are some ideas
such as even Knight H7 Knight G5 coming
in you also can play the move it takes
D4
and if you play C takes D4 this move is
very unusual actually but apparently it
works Queen D7
with the very direct idea to go to G4
here and let's say you play Bishop F1
Queen G4 anyway now you're threatening
the move Knight H3 again it's not very
human human way to play but apparently
this is very active here it's very hard
to get rid of these pieces here so now
one of the best options is to play G3
but again
I don't think we're going to see
something like this happening and giving
up the light score bishop and again this
is the best way to continue for white so
most likely when you're faced with the
move Queen G4 your logical responses
I'll just go here King H1 stepping
Knight H3 yes and now suddenly we see
the Dynamics in this position very
strong move D5 comes in now breaking the
center and now getting ready to get that
Bishop on F5 with the tempo so again we
don't if we don't want to open the
position but we play the move E5 now we
see the problem Bishop F5 hitting the
queen
and queen moves away 94 and look at the
activities of the black pieces here
black is actually much much better in
this position
it's a little bit tricky and uh
yeah it's wow black and sees the
initiative and let's uh jump to
Bucharest and check in with Christian
well just to give you a light insight on
that particular game I was having dinner
yesterday with Fabiano and his second
here in Bucharest and at the beginning
of the dinner they asked me to predict
the opening for tomorrow's game against
Anish and you know I started saying
Catalan or maybe the Berlin things of
that nature they didn't say anything at
the end of the dinner they said tomorrow
we're probably going to have the Italian
and I was like the Italian you haven't
been playing a lot of Italian recently
and he was uh like yeah we we have
something new uh ready that's an ominous
sign and an ominous message and I didn't
delve deep into the details obviously
that's not my business at this
competition and I let them go on with
their night and go get ready for uh at
the next day's match but there is
something new being cooked in the
caruana kitchen last night and and right
now is being essayed and shown on the
board being Anish understands that he
knows that he will have to solve some
problems some practical problems over
the chess board objectively it's very
difficult to find an advantage but you
can always find something practical to
play for and I think this is what we are
looking at right now and as I told you
guys at the beginning of the show Fabi
and Anish for that matter they're
definitely looking to score in uh this
round it's going to be a very very
intriguing matchup Christian I gotta ask
you who are the cooks you said that you
had dinner with Bobby and his second
trainer
who is Bobby's second trainer these days
yeah you're asking me the hot questions
yes hey yeah the inquiring minds want to
know much of an Insight right now but
I'm still not 100 so I'm not going to
give out any uh names we don't even get
a review but I I think I mean we've got
a scoop at this point
I cannot give you all the ingredients
yeah so I cannot give you all the
ingredients maybe and the people know
but and generally Fabi is not one to
hide uh things too much but it's not my
place to give you all uh the ingredients
Christian I'm not asking for the recipe
I don't want your secrets I just want to
know who's in the kitchen who are the
cooks all right my friend we'll let that
go and uh we would like to invite our
audience as always each and every day uh
social media send us your tweets how do
they do that you can send us tweets
using a hashtag super bad chess classic
or you can tag grantchester as well and
if you're watching uh YouTube or twitch
on St Louis chess club feel free to send
us questions there too join the
conversation and challenge us and in
fact we have a tweet wonderful let's go
yeah that was really quick this one is
from alpha chess move and it comes from
Twitter and this has got a question for
you yes sir can you comment on your 1989
game with Gary Kasparov scale of tea
Scholastic yes Sweden was this your most
prolific game with Gary this was a
absolutely first of all thank you for
the question and the fact that you would
even remember uh the scholastia game
that was for me a career defining game I
was playing the world champion Gary
sparov obviously and we played a Donnie
Brook uh one for the Aegis that was the
kiss game by the way where he made such
a howler I wanted to give him a kiss and
the crazy part is you know like this is
almost
I want to say a few months later we were
on a flight from Moscow to Spain
together
and we were sitting next to each other
we spent the entire flight
analyzing the game like he just didn't
want to give it he was trying to find
the truth in the position was I winning
did he have enough compensation for the
piece and it was just
what a Donnie Brook and I did my very
very best to capture all of our analysis
and notes for inside chess magazine that
I was publishing at the time and then
eventually I Incorporated those notes
into my book chest duels my duels with
all the world champions and some stories
and Gary
wow as world champion I got to tell you
he was just amazing amazing personality
folks and at the board he was kinetic
and energy personified and uh well I
love playing against Gary I just haven't
did you play him well it's strange I
mean you know in some ways it wasn't
that we played that much because these
guys you just saw that graphic three to
three and 29 draws we only played like a
dozen games but they feel like each and
every month
Yeah well yeah but again you know the
the modern players are playing a lot
more but we played an enormous amount of
Blitz games together we we know and in
that tournament in scholastia
Gary was Furious
Furious because in the last round he was
in clear first karpov won the game tied
for first with Gary and Gary was really
angry that he had tied for first with
karpov even though he won the GMA Grand
Tour and he comes storming into the
players room and he says yes sir
I I need some money
I'm gonna I'm gonna kill you
in Blitz
so that I can go buy dinner
so we're gonna play for 10 bucks a game
doesn't matter
and I said Gary
we're gonna play Blitz and you may win
but you're only gonna win a Happy Meal
and I mean we wait I'm not joking I mean
something like nine in the evening to
three o'clock in the morning and he was
plus two
so is that even it was that even and not
only that all the McDonald's are closed
I didn't even get the dinner it was
pretty fun so I and I played Gary all
over the world Blitz we both enjoy Bliss
he normally got the best of me and but
the matches were really a lot of fun
really really really competitive and a
lot of great story I mean Gary was a
really he loved playing Blitz he just
loved chess he loved playing and when
you got a chance to play the world
champion I don't care what time it did
you say I agree I'm there I'm there
thank you for the question thank you
very much and avar I think you too
certainly enjoy a good Blitz match now
and then against the top players if
Lavon aronian gives you a call I don't
care midnight says come over let's play
Blitz you're gonna say yes absolutely
yes and I enjoy playing Blitz especially
with Levon and again it's very hard to
play him and you know in in his trash
talking also you know he not only he
beats you but the trash talking he's so
skilled and yeah I really played Blitz
with a lot of very very top players in
fact we do a lot of training on Blitz
with uh students from the St Louis
University and uh we are looking forward
possibly playing in the world rapid
templates tournament this year so it's
an event that everyone is excited and
I've played once in 2017 and really
enjoyed it at Blitz I would say it's
always been a big fun for me to play
against very very top players always
enjoy it and it's a good part of my
training to stay in shape
now you've got the game of Duda and
farrugia behind you and you were telling
us about these Bishop take C6 and B take
C6 first of all update the position for
us and are we still in opening Theory uh
we are still in theory here but
something very interesting I want to
mention here so after the move Bishop C6
here in this position not Rook C8 uh not
not Rook C8 not only that he spent about
almost 20 minutes on this move 94 and
the main move here is of course The Rook
C8 which I showed here BC was played a
few times and 94 is the second most
popular move in this position there are
some games between Grand Masters Peter
Heine and Nielsen had a game uh so it's
it's a it's a possible move here but
definitely I think alireza is trying to
avoid the 68 line because there you
don't have any chances in that end game
that I showed you're just trying to make
a draw here but I think he's looking for
some potential chances here Knight E4
Queen A3 is the best move here Queen is
actually very well placed in this
position because it cannot be attacked
and also putting pressure on A7 and most
importantly controlling the C5 Square
this is something you want to try to
prevent not allow black to play this
move C5 because the C6 spawn is a
backward Pawn here and now he played the
move Rook C1 in this position Knight E5
has been played six times
um a h Castle is another a possibility
H3 was played but Rook C1 is very rare
only two games played and uh definitely
a logical move because you're putting
pressure on C6 and now black should
respond here one of the best moves here
for him is to play the move Rook C8
and it's actually very interesting asset
the best move at least for now the depth
is not too high on the engine is
actually say white can play the move
Knight G1 say what
with the idea to play F3 and get rid of
the Knight because when you play F3 the
Knight doesn't have any good squares to
retreat except going back to F6 and then
you have a full control of the C5 square
of course this is a move We're Not Gonna
See most likely we'll see the move
Castle but it's just kind of curious
that this move is actually possible to
play if you Castle sometimes you have to
be careful black can actually go for G5
in this position so you really have to
calculate these positions after F6 now
black can play the move H5 H4 and try to
get some Contra play here but here white
can play Rook fd1
H5 and very important to get rid of this
Knight only four because it's always
very annoying so you play the move
Knight D2 here try to exchange and get
the bishop on D6 here but the following
line it's it's kind of forced here now
Bishop takes E4 you can play Bishop D6
and hear you a little bit better because
now Rook has to go away you have F3 and
you also have all the weaknesses here on
C6 C6 and A7 so let's see if there is
another move uh black can play here
actually there's a big difference here
you have to take back with the pawn in
order not to lose that Tempo after F3 so
Bishop D6
Rook F7 and this position is more or
less equal there is some Contra play
coming up with H3 and if you play the
move H3 as well this is going to be in
Hook because black can play Rook G7 and
get some control play later on with the
move G4 thank you for that let's take a
look at ferruges line score and how he
got here he started in the worst
possible way let's see he started with a
loss against Wesley so and then after
two draws he came back with two wins
back to back very very nice and he
didn't stop there either no yesterday
what a beautiful game he won against
Yani pomichi and today I mean a lot at
stake in this game versus do that and I
just had to say VAR that moved Knight G1
no no no no but if you were gonna go for
F2 F3 in such a position like I think
you said Rook C8 so if I had it in my
mind
yes you gotta play F3 you gotta play F3
you gotta move your knight I'm not going
Knight G1 I'm going Knight E5 in order
to play F3 and maybe who knows on a good
day I could get in G4 and a why didn't
the computer like 95. it's a very
specific reason actually but 95 is a
move you're always looking forward to
play here and then F3 will be very
strong but here black has a very strong
response and that is C5 C5 yes a move I
thought I had under control actually it
seems like we have the control here we
have three pieces guarding the C5 square
but the problem now is as soon as we
take Yasser the move F6 comes in with
the tempo and then we move the Knight
let's say 19. another Tempo move E5
comes in and now black has a complete
control of the center and we cannot go
to uh G3 in this position because after
Knight takes G3 we're gonna there there
is a pressure on D3 as well here so also
Bishop G3 right another idea Bishop G3
actually D4 comes in opening up the
position here and now we see a lot of
pressure on D3 on the D5 and again the
king is still in the middle and that's
that is a big problem here actually
white is already in in serious trouble
wow perhaps you have to play the move
Knight F3 here but also here E5 at least
it's a little bit more stable Bishop G3
and now we see this idea G5 and then H5
H4 because you have such a strong Center
in this position uh the compensation is
uh uh it's really good compensation for
blackish just for one Pawn get in that
position it looks very good for black it
does indeed and it's kind of a
remarkable uh turn around you know you
play Knight on F3 the E5 and you're
thinking you know like I've got C C6 I'm
ready to capture on C6 I've got C5 under
control and all I need is just one tempo
to play F3 and I'm gold and then the
turnaround happened uh really really
fast uh again a big shout out to our
audience thank you for your questions
keeping us on our toes more social media
by all means as we are in our
Championship rounds we haven't seen MBL
versus uh uh Daniel they're following
the game that I mentioned that was
played by DX except there's one
difference and Bill didn't take on A7
right yes yeah but we do have that
feature that's an improvement or not but
it's slightly different
she could always transfer
Ence so we're expecting after the move
Rook uh D1 that black slightly behind in
development might might not want to
trade uh the Rooks but the move Rook E8
you know preps C6 potentially preparing
B5 but even more importantly if I can
get rid of this aggressive
very aggressive Vision you know if I can
get rid of this aggressive Bishop
curious yes but maybe I don't understand
this position that well since I don't
have experience
xp7 Bishop C6 because that's all right
listen to me well it's it's one of those
things whenever I see that I voluntarily
pin myself like I this I had this inner
Revolution yeah okay it is temporary uh
and I always I I have this inherent fear
that I'm setting myself up for some kind
of a tactical loss I don't know if I can
take advantage of it right away but
assuming I'm playing Knight E3 why else
did I put my knight on C2 if not
deflated the E3 Square let's say I drop
my Rook back to a in order to to break
the pin and simply defending the Rook I
I mean I'm looking at it now see I don't
see anything you know convincing that or
I'm not necessarily convincing myself
that I have
Advantage but let's let's just pursue it
a move or two so Knight D5 gift me the
pawn or let me double your Pawn probably
you're going to trade yes I'll take now
give me this guy do I have Bishop C6
here right that's the problem Bishop to
C6 and I don't have time uh to do
anything uh absolutely wonderful no and
if I take with the bishop
uh gift me this Pawn
probably C6 now I will have to play C6
and then probably quickly Bishop G4
maybe on the next move yeah well it
seems to me like you're solving you're
solving uh I didn't uh do anything to
disrupt you from that
um
I don't see anything immediate no
okay say it's possible it's definitely
possible the ACT did play rookie eight
instead of Bishop D7
yeah uh but two nasi's point there VAR
uh I mean if you can solve your problems
opening problems in the way that she
wants to and get a firm equality that's
great
did I miss something I I didn't see a
way of uh exploiting her move order no I
think Bishop D7 was actually slightly
more accurate yeah then the move that
rookie 8 played rookie there is a little
bit of an edge here I'll show a couple
of uh moves there is a chance maybe for
mvl to have a very small advantage in
this position now after rookie 8. so
here he should uh start with taking on
A7
now Rook takes F7 and now you move this
Knight to D2
okay because then you want to put the
pawn on F3 to make sure this Knight is
misplaced on F6 here so and then you can
play Knight E3 and try to bring the
Knight on D5 so one option here is the
move C6 to control the D5 square but
also that weakens a little bit the dark
Square D6 and b60 and here I like this
move A4 to make sure black cannot play
the move B5
and again a little bit awkward still
this Rook on A7 the bishop is on C8 and
at some point even if we exchange
Bishops this Knight is going to be very
well placed on C4 putting pressure on A5
and E5 Pawn there's a weakness uh weak
squares on B6 and D6 here as well so
King f8 for example Knight E3 and uh you
you have to play now like maybe B6 or
Bishop B7 very slightly better position
for white uh after F3 maybe you can even
play the move Knight B3 double up the
Rooks uh I see a small Edge in this
position for nvl by the way we do have
the move Knight D2 without the capture
on A7 uh on the board and uh kind of
along the same lines that you're just
discussing white is looking to play F2
F3 and kind of make the Knight on F6
look a little bit uh well poorly placed
I'll just leave it uh there for for the
moment and I'll just point out that in
the game Carolina Geary Anisha is still
thinking after Bishop A3
by the way I love that line that VAR was
showing because it's a very unusual line
I want to say I think we started with
Queen D7 immediately or maybe it was
Knight F4 immediately the idea of Knight
F4 is you just go like hey you know my
night's on G6 it wants to go to F4
eyeballing G2 D3 and if you play very
natural looking Queen C2 move well then
just suddenly and shockingly out of the
blue you know comes Queen D7 and when
you drop back anticipating Queen G4 this
capture capture Queen G4
and suddenly this queen has teleported
itself across the board to G4 where it's
really being aggressive the most
immediately threat
is Knight H3 check pardon me Knight H3
check and picking up the F2 Pawn King H1
looks like a really reasonable move
until you see D5
you think okay E5 and suddenly wait a
minute whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa the
initiative is all on one side of the
board this comes with a gain of tempo
Knight is ready to jump to E4 and it's
looking really really good now having
said and plug develops so quickly well
look at those A Fistful of pieces on the
king side now having said this uh now
see uh Anish has been thinking for the
last half hour that's what I wanted to
say I mean at clock times now we saw it
yesterday against ding he also thought
but he found all of those good gorgeous
moves as well sorry please uh time might
be an issue in this game like if he gets
himself into time trouble because we're
only on move 13 right it is super early
in the game and while he's trying to
figure out the best way to deal with
this summer of a novel idea that Fabi
presented
in critical moments he will need that
time to figure out what to do exactly
and uh he looks stressed he looks very
stressed like because fact is scary
preparation is definitely frightening
yeah and when he comes in and plays all
this moves fast and it's something you
haven't seen before and look at this
extra scary he is reaching for he now in
principle this is why Anish was spending
so much time in principle the move E5
takes D4 is what we would call a No-No
you don't do this because if you don't
have something immediate like d65 or you
know play against the pawn on e4 because
of the bishop being on G4 the idea is
the C3 Pawn which is a little bit
passive not doing anymore surprise
surprise Fabi instantly responded with
Queen B3 he didn't take the pawn back
what we're going to cancel his
membership into the pond grubbers Club
immediately so Fabi was absolutely
prepped for E5 takes D4 I just to finish
the thought however after the recapture
C3 white has this Central Pawn do and
with a board full of pieces these
Central pawns our predecessors have
proven significant advantages for white
so normally speaking you don't trade off
this good E5 Pawn for this bad C3 Pawn
but but Anish had a very specific idea
and he's not going to get the chance to
show it because uh Bobby also has a very
specific idea he played Queen B3
instantly and I gotta assume that this
was a top move from the engine because
uh fabby's preparation so good VAR jump
in absolutely this is the really scary
part Bobby plays this movie immediately
and there's almost 50 minutes advantage
on the clock here and most likely he has
analyzed the next 10 moves also next 10
best moves for black and this is a
really scary prep and once again we see
how strong is fabi's opening preparation
so let's take a look what can Anish do
here I really like that Knight F4 line
we were discussing with that Queen D7
Queen G4 right but uh Ed move it's
something that I would be a little bit
hesitant to play when I see opponent is
prepared because most likely he had
analyzed this edcd D5
line so but let's see here what can
Anish do in this position to neutralize
the position well first of all two quick
questions for you is this still
a theory I mean was the move Queen B3 a
novelty in other words and if so uh
statistically how how is it supposed to
be Queen Victoria still played in that
one game it has been following that one
game okay after Queen B3 and now the
threat is to uh check take one F to take
on F7 here in that game black played the
move Bishop E6
and again the game between two about
about 2600 Grand Masters that ended in a
draw Bishop E6 uh and if Bishop takes E6
uh rookie six
and C takes D4 and black black played
Queen D7 here looks like black is
playing a lot of the most precise moves
and the idea is to double up the Rooks
and try to put pressure only for here a
very small Advantage here for white uh
but another option here I see for black
here is to probably move D5 which is
exactly top move of engines in this
position it makes sense you want to
blockade this diagonal of course the
main move to consider first is to take
it takes D5
now black can take on C3 immediately or
can try to exchange the Rook let's say
if you exchange the Rooks first
Rook takes E1 and then D takes C3 attack
in the Knight
and now
if you if you take back Queen C3 then
there is Knight takes D5 you actually
can capture this pawn and it's a sharp
it's a sharp line
Queen D5 it looks scary it looks scary
yeah it looks scary but somehow it's
just it's it's uh evaluation is just
equal but wow that pin of the okay it's
not easy to get out that thing either no
it's not something I would want to
volunteer earlier law but continue uh
yeah so
um and uh yeah if you play Queen C4 then
there is this queen F5 in this position
and uh somehow Black is Black is okay
here now you're threatening to play the
move Bishop Bishop E6 next so very very
very complicated so after the move Queen
B3 uh I have a question it should be six
is probably with a safer Choice
um uh can Anish still play the idea you
suggested earlier so if he starts with
queen D7 right now right now
F4 and queen G4 in the future
seven yeah and let's say Knight F4 right
Knight F4 in this position here
um the problem might be maybe that there
there is a move G3 here immediately
attack in the Knight and if you play the
move Queen G4 there is Bishop F7 now
right so Knight H3 check it's still
playable actually King G2 you can play
the move Knight G5 here
and uh
Knight takes G5 Pawn takes G5
still something interesting but black
didn't manage to deal with the center
but okay uh but now say to your point
you've got Queen H3 check on your agenda
and maybe on a good day Knight G4 you're
not
that terribly worried and you have a
good pressure on the on the center the
E4 is hanging the four is hanging looks
like this could be this could be
playable actually as well
um but Anish is still thinking at the
moment and
well this of course is a huge game it's
a game for first place if Fabi can win
the game and kick Anish down the land
the ladder there I well obviously he
would not be in first place position
going uh but as we prepare for our break
a couple of results as far right we had
two quick draws today I think versus
Robert and me promise against the Wesley
South
not unexpected in the beginning versus
Richie report game as we prepare for
break before we're gonna go on break we
always like to check in on our friends
at Q Boutique St louis.com to find out
what they have as a special well take a
look
very handsome chess set the stunning set
will make a statement in any room these
traditional Staunton style metal
Chessmen are handcrafted in Italy and
feature a three-inch King the unique
octagonal Alabaster board features a
wooden frame around the border and a
storage drawer board is 17 by 17 with
one and a half inch squares octagonal
Alabaster board easy for me to say got
myself Tongue Tied there but yeah the
storage drawers are a really nice
addition to the handsome set
all your shopping needs uh check out Q
Boutique we'll see on the other side of
our first break
[Music]
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why chess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the games the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit worldchess hof.org
in 2019 the Missouri Bicentennial
commission along with Governor Mike
Parsons approved the building of a
life-size chess board to celebrate the
200th anniversary of the state of
Missouri Dr Jeannie sinkfield a lifelong
patron of scouting in Great Rivers
Council board member proposed that the
project be built as an Eagle Scout
project Jeannie invited 16 year old
Andrew Dowden of troop 6 Jefferson City
to take on this incredibly important
project
my name is Andrew Dowden and I belong to
troop 6 in Jefferson City Missouri so my
troop we were down camping down at the
sing fields and Jeannie came down and
asked you know is anyone close to
getting their eagle or needing a project
she had this idea of the Eagle Scout
project chessboard and she wanted
somebody to kind of work with her to see
what we could come up with at the time I
kind of had a project in line but when
she brought up this idea obviously I
wanted to choose it because it was a lot
better idea than what I had started
prior to this project I did not really
know anything about Chess once I got
into this project I downloaded an app on
my phone started playing chess and I
took the chest merit badge down at Scout
camp this was a bicentennial chessboard
for the Historical Society of Missouri
there were a lot of people that helped
me with this project because whenever I
I got the pictures from the Historical
Society to engrave onto the granite I
wasn't very familiar with the technology
needed to engrave on there so I needed
some assistance with that and learning
how to do it and after all that I'm
pretty sure I know how to do it now so
to engrave those Edge pieces I went down
to the Lake of the Ozarks Scout
Reservation and we use the epilogue
laser me and Thomas Yang did I wasn't
really expecting it to end out this big
but as we me and Jeannie were working
um it just got kind of got bigger and
bigger and bigger which I didn't have a
problem with I thought you know I can
take on a little bit more and a little
bit more and
it ended out to be a really really cool
project so we had a ribbon cutting of
the chess board and there were a whole
bunch of people there including the
governor the St Louis chess club the
World Chess Hall of Fame the State
Historical Society which all helped out
during this entire project Jeannie was
there I had to give a little speech that
I didn't really know I had to do but
that kind has taught me a little bit
about speaking too so I think that has
helped me too this project it's made me
real proud that everyone is enjoying it
like every time I go down there
somebody's playing
and then they're taking care of it which
really makes me proud because me sinking
all that time and everyone else that's
helped me sinking in all that time I
like to see people use it but I also
like to see people appreciate it
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage of the super bet round
eight Championship rounds uh two left
and uh as we were on our break we were
looking at Anish giri and he had the
look of somebody who's absolutely
suffering I look I I see that body
posture and I'm thinking to myself
no see he's trying to remember his file
it's like you know he's not even
calculating at the board it's like what
did I what did I write oh I remember now
I'm supposed to recapture with my queen
uh why is he suffering and is he
suffering I think his position's fine
but is there something I'm missing his
position is completely fine but walking
into your opponent's preparation is
always very unpleasant right and uh VAR
jump in is there some preparation that
Anish is worried about absolutely Yasser
and it's again incredible preparation by
Fabiano and if Anish finds All the Right
Moves I think he will make a draw here
with a repetition but he really needs to
find it and it's really really scary
right now he's more than one hour behind
on the clock and as you can see on a
screen 134 for Fabiana 29 for on this
year and the key move is right now here
guys Queen takes E1 he needs to
sacrifice his Queen in this position
otherwise he will be slightly worse let
me show you the key lines after the
queen sacrifice okay so Queen takes E1
if you play Queen d8 after Queen C3
white is a little bit better here
because of the better development here
again not a big advantage or anything
that Knight D5 line it's very possible
that Fabiano probably analyzed another
10 moves deeper with the best computers
and there there are some small problems
for black here but if Anish plays the
move Queen E1 here right 91 takes on D2
now the Knight is under attack
Knight F3 Knight F3 is the only move
now you're trying to capture the pawn on
D2 and now white plays the move you can
play both Knight E4 or Knight G4
actually it's gonna lead to the same
thing now you're attacking the pawn on
F2 and here now white needs to find the
only move otherwise he is in serious
trouble the move is D6 here right
attacking F7 makes sense Knight takes F2
you are getting ready to promote the
spawn into a queen with D1 and uh the
way the game ends in a draw here is
actually very nice Bishop F7 King h8 you
have to capture the pawn back and then
Knight E4 comes in and now you cannot
play the move King F1 because you can
lose your queen after Knight E2 and
black is just winning so you're gonna be
forced to play the move King H1 Knight
F2 check King G1 Knight E4 and this is
how the game can potentially end here
wow well not that difficult the
calculation actually once you get to the
position after Knight E4 so I think
Anish Gary is actually you know
calculating Queen takes E1 and once you
see this move Knight E4 because I think
that's the hard follow-up he's gone for
it yeah you see him Reaching Across the
board and ready to play Queen takes E1 I
think the time is the factor too that
precipitates this move Queen takes E1
being an hour down on the clock at this
level
I mean that's almost a suicide right but
if you can force the draw and he can
calculate Queen e191 takes on on D2 uh
Knight F3 if you don't see Knight E4
right away it's easy to reject this line
because materially speaking you're going
to be only a rook and minor piece after
Knight takes D2 for the queen and you're
going to be close to losing but the move
Knight E4 however temporarily does the
fridge and he does it he does it another
reason I like to move Queen E1 yes sir
it's forcing the matters exactly and if
you play Queen dear you're more than an
hour behind on a clock and again
opponent is in prep but here I think he
uh you you finding the best move Queen
E1 and to very likely you haven't done
anything wrong to be losing in this
position exactly so and now I think and
there he goes looks like he's gonna find
a move and now Fabi has to play the move
D6 right uh according to the angels
everything else is really really bad
here and
this is very impressive it's uh it's a
little bit of a gamble right we can say
for fabi's part you know going to this
line that it's just uh it's a fourth
draw but hoping maybe Anish wouldn't do
it but now Anish finds all the key moves
and looks like the game should end in a
draw well I mean we have uh uh trumpeted
uh the great prowess of fabi's opening
uh preparation to the skies well we got
to do the Hat tip to Anish as well he
has played Queenie one boldly
sacrificing his Queen gun Knight E4 and
passed the torch and said okay your turn
I mean I I mean it almost looks like
somebody failed to take the pawn on D2
off the board right we were setting up
the pieces from a previous game and
somehow we left the black Pawn on D2
but with this black Pawn on D2 with the
pawn on F2 under attack you know you you
got to do something in this move D7
pardon me D5 D6 suggests itself is you
attack F7 but that line that you read
that you showed VAR that was pretty
convincing Knight takes threatens the
queen
Bishop takes F7 King h8 very important
King h8 King h8 best move don't walk
into this bishop and don't walk into a
check with that Bishop now you're
threatening the queen hello so
only moves now night jacket and as you
were saying for King F1 walks into a
royal Fork you'll lose your queen can't
do it you have to just secede to a
Perpetual check and this is one of those
games which kind of uh is super
irritating but this is one of those
games that afterwards
the accuracy of the players it's like
Perfect Right 100 every move was engine
approved you know because uh it feels
like prep from start to finish yeah
impressive I am very impressed by Anish
she took his time and found all the best
most being caught in a very difficult
preparation in a very unpleasant
preparation but he makes an easy draw
now with the black pieces and look at
him go they are speeding I found all
this moves at the board or he remember
he was trying to remember I think that
whole angst that hey that that look of
you know absolute anguish you know yeah
nobody suffers quite as well as these
chess Grand Masters you know and he
really had a suffering
and as we get ready for today our
semi-final broadcast tomorrow is our
last broadcast we took a poll are we
headed for a playoff and the answers are
these are the results of 48 saying yes
two players will have a playoff right 39
I think no it'll be one outright and 11
thought that yes three or more players
will be tied
uh yeah
uh I'm in the I don't know category
until I look at the game of farugia for
just a moment because uh uh when we left
that game things were really kind of
heated up uh let's see we were just
about here B takes uh pardon me 94 B
take C6 Rook C1 and then we were looking
at this move G5 right
and this came this was a key moment
right here and Duda played Knight D2 not
the very first move that comes to your
mind because after all you'll be leaving
your king in the center but he properly
reasoned
that even if his King is exposed in the
center of the board the Bishops of
opposite color his control over the C5
break means that his King will be
relatively safe yes nothing to worry
about farugia end up capturing capturing
King G7 Rook C5 we're up to date with
the players so we have avoided opposite
color Bishop positions we have uh the
imbalances are quite clear blacks
backward parlon C6 uh potential weakness
as well of the A7 Pawn
maybe is a little bit the the dynamic
play as soon as white makes a decision
of castling well we are open to the idea
of h5h4 King G7 also is a reveal of
swords that we are looking to open the
king side with h5h4 work h8
um yes sir would you consider living the
king in the center here oh very much yes
very much so I I I I'm I'm a little bit
surprised by the decision to play Rook
C5 because as you were about to say
leaving the king in the center means
maybe you know you want to put your
knight on one of these outposts right
whether it be C5 or E5 and you kind of
feel like your king might want to be on
D2 whereas you are taking some Liberty
but Rook C5 and
um
well uh
I don't know I'm I'm uncertain uh far uh
help me out this isn't an e this is not
an easy imbalance to judge
yes I think uh White is actually a
little bit better in this position
because of dark Square weaknesses not
not a big Advantage here but there were
a couple of interesting moves before
that I want to show you guys especially
after the move G5
so if we go back if you in this position
dude I had another interesting
alternative in this position when the G5
move was played Bishop G3 is absolutely
fine here but you have this move guys
Knight takes G5
hello sacrificing a night it's a
temporarily sacrifice then you play the
move H4 hello forcing the Knight to go
back on e4
and then you play the move F3
again you have to retreat to F6
and then you can play them with G4 this
was another interesting idea and uh
actually the best move in this position
is to play the move Bishop E4 because
after Bishop page five you're going to
be attacked by H5 so you play the move
Bishop B4 and it takes 94 and this
position is it's unclear even though
maybe you know white can take a Pawn on
C6 but the Knight only four it's gonna
be uh an outpost that you can never
really remove so I think black will have
enough compensation here just an
interesting idea Knight takes G5 that
white hat but he played the move Bishop
G3 which is normal and again the main
goal in this position for white is try
to get rid of this Knight if you can do
that then you're gonna be better because
you have a much better structure
weaknesses on C6 and A7 here so here I
think
inaccurate move here by alireza he
played the move Rook C8 this is too slow
he needed to play the move H5
immediately in this position to threaten
this move H4 and this is the best way to
continue and it's not easy to to stop
this move H6 here so one of the key
lines is to play H4 to prevent that but
then you play G4 Knight D2 right and now
we get a similar position in the game
but as you can see the structure
structure is not as good you know with
double pawns on G file the weakness only
three so here actually black is doing
black is doing fine here after Queen B6
and uh but in the game he played the
move Rook C8 which is going to allow the
move Knight D2 really nice move here now
you want to exchange the Knight it may
seem like wait a minute after capture
your king is going to be in the middle
but there is absolutely no danger here
and the king is very well placed here
now the Rooks are connected as well
black just doesn't have any pieces to
attack the king here so that's why he
didn't take on D2 and he decided to
capture on G3 but now the H file is open
there is some pressure here as well and
King G7
and after Rook C5 it's actually a very
nice Advantage here for white weaknesses
on C6 A7 the reason you don't you don't
want to cancel here immediately because
there could be some H5 H4 immediately
black can start an attack-ish
so yeah Rook C5 played and now we see
that Rook h8 is played uh black really
needs to do something in this position
here so that's why we see the move Rook
h8 try to create some counter play with
H5 H4 otherwise it could be really
really bad here for black
thank you VAR for that and our results
so far Nasi right we have three draws
already dig against rapper Carolina
against Gary and Nepal Michigan and that
Bobby versus Gary draw that was a
remarkable piece of preparation by both
players as Bobby played the game
a la Tempo Gary was an hour behind on
the clock but a very forcing perpetual
and a convincing draw
which really opens up a window of
opportunity for farrugia a win today
and our reigning grantchester champion
from 2022 would become Soul leaders it's
all leader with one game to go now uh
that variation that you showed us VAR uh
I love it when I can prove the computer
wrong I just I live for these moments
in this particular position pardon me
where you have let's say Knight takes D2
King takes D2 and this idea that the
white king is perfectly safe thanks to
the Bishops of opposite color in the
center of the board it's very very
difficult for black to coordinate a
breakout with pawns on us C5 and E5 what
I wanted to point out was this moment
where you had mentioned the move H5 and
I agree that
in this exact position I would say
that's the most challenging move you
know you get to play h5h I have to play
H4 and as VAR was mentioning
this is quite a different kettle of fish
because the king side structure is
compromised but I got to tell you I love
this position for white really yes
because now when I Castle my king is not
in the center on the contrary I think my
king will go to the H2 Square world yeah
I love that I'm so safe I mean I feel
like I'm in a warm cocoon and nobody
will ever bother me and then I'll really
really start to focus on some dark
swears and by the way once you've put
the pawns on H5 I mean okay it still
work but let me introduce my queen on
the G5 square with or without Rook takes
F5 and I've got what I think at least is
a very promising attack I love these
positions for white I think the the yeah
King is really safe practical game why
seems like to have a lot of ideas and
King is extremely safe okay I love that
I love that so guys I want to mention
here that makes a difference I agree
with you completely if black plays
slowly here like doesn't do anything
immediately you're gonna put the Rook on
C5 King on H2 Knight B3 Knight A5 and
you're you're gonna feel like I'm almost
winning here dream guys it's very
specific way black needs to play in this
position otherwise he is much much worse
and the key move here is the move A5 A5
yes with the idea of Queen B4 at some
point just try to create some Contra
play because the Knight on D2 needs
couple of moves to get into the game
because right now it's kind of passive
only two you really don't have any
squares to go to Every score is guarded
so A5 is a very strong move in this
position to try to maintain the balancer
and it's it's not so easy what to do
here B3 is the recommended move here uh
for white but at the same time we don't
want to play that move because we're
really hoping to get the Knight on C5 at
some point here Queen E7 looks
interesting but that will run into the
move F6 and you're really not gonna get
to the gym as much as we want yeah and
let's say if we just follow it through
with the Rook C5 I did now it's actually
black is a little bit better after the
move Queen B4 wow I would never have
guessed that yeah so for example like
this end game after the exchanges and
since since the bishop is very very
powerful on F5 in this position after
Rook FC to my surprise as well guys here
this is actually a good Advantage here
for black because you're going to have
to take if we play this move Rook fc1
then
wow this is really amazing Rook B8 and
now the Rook is going to come to the
second Rank and with the bishop only for
now we see the problem with this
structure here when the Rook is on a
second rank Bishop E4 comes in you're
gonna have really difficult difficulties
here to defending that this end game is
actually now it's just almost losing now
but for one question just few moves back
instead of exchanging Queens on uh three
can I sacrifice Rook F5 and Go 23 right
here yes Rook F5 is a possibility
because
it's an option here sorry because if I
play Queen A3 here to trade you have
this nice move Rook G5 check important
in there very important internet so it
takes F5 Queen D3 trying to bring the
queen looks scary into the game but
luckily this Knight doesn't have a good
way to get in into the game immediately
and here you can play Rook athlete or
Rook A8 both moves are possible so let's
say Rook
fe8 and
probably Queen F5 if only my knight
wasn't yeah I know I mean
a horse a horse give me a good one you
can play Knight F5 but after yeah after
Knight F1 rookie six black black relax
relaxation
so let's go to Romania we have Christian
with Fabi
Fabi uh quite an unfortunate situation
for you you came out with blazing hot
preparation but Annie's just defended
immaculately tell us a bit about your
perspective yeah we actually discussed a
bit after the game because I was curious
about like what he was thinking during
the game and he was also I guess curious
about about what I uh I mean the what
the position objectively was but yeah he
found everything absolutely correct I
mean this position has been played a lot
actually he knew that there was a game
shanklined Irvin Evan lemieu so he he
knew this game but it's everyone plays
Queen D3 everyone plays this position
and I saw there's like some matlakov
against krishnu from title Tuesday
where they play like H3 and like can
play many many possible moves and
so I came up with this
very rare movie I knew that it was
played in this game seems that only one
game has been played with this move yeah
and they actually they went up to I mean
black has many choices here so I was
thinking
maybe that this is a moment where Anish
would play something else besides ed4
because ed4 is very concrete then I
thought he could play C6 for example but
Bishop A3 discouraged that discourages
out a bit and then he has very
interesting moves Bishop G4
um H3 and either Bishop takes F3 or
Bishop H5 or Knight F4
so basically black can play anything at
this point more or less yeah I can play
Anything For example D5 is a move that
was very tempting to him and it looks
very tempting but he spotted this trick
but uh it's it's the only reason why
this is bad but the bishop gets kind of
solidified on D5 with C4
um so he he's saw this and he said that
he wasn't like considering Knight of
four Bishops before even I understand
why because they're interesting moves
but they're not super concrete so he was
going for the more concrete stuff it's
very very sensible and yeah there was a
game with Bishop B6 here where black is
a bit worse I was hoping that I might
get that position which is not it's not
concrete like basically I mean black is
not doing terribly here but white has
the center Queen C2 and a slight
advantage
certainly
and this is
yeah the thing is like
DC3 is very accurate if he had gone for
this I think that this is really
difficult for black
to uh to play because you you can go for
this position
but uh White has this very tricking with
queen and I thought I thought he might
not be too afraid of this because it
looks like
yeah you're pinned but but you I mean
white has to do something because Queen
D7 is coming right so it's possible to
maybe overlook this move and then you
get into basically so the point being
that after queen queen E4 Queen E4 and
F5 Queen E2 I think I think this is one
another four Queen E7
um because there's like a May 135
actually I I was trying to figure this
out over the board because I have no
idea what
I mean I I didn't think that I would get
to this at this point I was considering
this position
and couldn't understand it but I thought
it's so dangerous black I see the
computer says
B6 and I thought King E2 was winning a
piece
F4 okay yeah I didn't see this F4 yeah
yeah I so I was calculating this but uh
understandably he didn't want to
deal for it was this still in your files
if you I just knew Queen I just knew
Queen C4 that was that was it I mean the
position from the start is like not
concrete at all so basically it's
difficult to analyze everything and
Bishop 5 here is also possible 95 and
it's again a mess but it's dangerous for
black
but I really thought he would be
attracted to Knight takes E8
um and he spent a lot of time well at
least
yeah I thought he would be attracted to
this position because it's it's more or
less a normal position yeah and the
position is equal and I also haven't
like prepared anything here I just knew
that it's a more or less playable
position uh but I have like an hour time
Advantage so you can play so this was my
my hope that I have a playable position
our time advantage and it looks fine for
black so I thought maybe he would you
know put his Knight here we would get
something like this and uh yeah it's
probably about equal but uh continue the
game for a while the game continues and
I was very disappointed when he
basically just played everything and
after Queen E8 everything is forced
right yeah I mean at this point I
understood that of course he's he's
gonna take I mean
there wasn't much hope that he would
play Queen d8
the problem is that in this position
white actually loses with any of them
for like I think King F1 loses to Bishop
G4 and then Bishop takes F3 and Knight
F2 were nice C3 ideas
um so white is at White Hand is forced
and
it's not very difficult to calculate
because you have this mechanism so like
why it doesn't have checks it's just the
only thing that would be scary for black
so you just have this mechanism which
draws yeah um so yeah overall like
Danish um
did everything absolutely correct today
yeah uh difficult well not so difficult
but uh still disappointing really late
again without with more time on my clock
than when I finished much more time like
five five minutes or so so five minutes
is a long time that's an accomplishment
well you don't unfortunately get extra
points for for the time you saved up
during the tournaments your co-leader
going into uh this round alireza is
under some pressure how would you assess
this position right now
I mean I feel like white is definitely
better but under pressure is a bit uh
difficult to say because he has ideas so
it's not like he's passive which I think
he played a good decision here to take
on G3 because if you play this kind of
position then you have no counter play
and why just plays H4 and the King on D2
is safe yeah so he he made a good
decision to uh
should I see that
like fg3 was an option but okay h23 is
kind of normal like you open the they
trial
um like young Kristoff is playing
extremely principled right he's just
grabbing the pawn and then what we're
gonna see is probably I mean H5 or queen
F6 I don't know okay some queen of six
something like this
um so white is going to be a pull up and
black is trying to find some kind of
play yeah you get H4 and you white king
is a bit uh I see the computer hates it
but in Practical game it's not like
let's just see what
and Bishop G6 but this is like I don't
see what it changes I don't see what
this changes so so I think normally you
play H5
and then maybe you but the thing is h4u
you'll probably like run into taken
Queen E7
so
so you maybe you should play Queen of
maybe G4 to stop this Knight of three is
a good idea you could even consider it
at this moment yeah yeah just stop stop
Knight F3 because
um
like given time white white is going to
be winning so you need to stop the the
counter play with Knight of three E5
Fabi thank you very much for your
insights you still have one game left
against Richie we'll let you go get
ready for that and we'll see you
tomorrow
thank you Christian thank you uh Fabi at
times I feel like the players are taking
over our jobs as commentators they they
really enjoy it and that game of uh Ali
Raza is going to be for all the marbles
because a lot of games are heading
already for uh quick drops three I saw a
repetition was being offered in the game
between mvl and dioc so everything to
play for in this one remaining game
but we have some social media tweets
let's have a look and see
um what our audience is going to test us
on
here it comes this is from Carson from
the YouTube yes sir I've heard you
mentioned the pawn Grabber Society I was
wondering about the origins of it and
how do I become a member exactly
everybody's looking for a gold card
membership all you gotta do is uh play
risky chess don't worry about your king
just go for it grab your pawns and we'll
make sure you get an honorary membership
the origins really are back at the
Pacific Northwest that was where we
really started I became known as the
pond grubber and you know the Palm
grubber Society was slowly slowly slowly
born but yeah I think a lot of people
over the course of their careers yeah
have become very very materialistic and
don't worry you too can have a special
membership thank you and more oh
let's jump back to Bucharest and this
time getting a different perspective
with Anish
we do want to get anish's perspective on
this game Onish when your opponent
finishes with 1 hour and 35 minutes on
their clock well you must have survived
a big scare in this one yeah what can I
say great great by Fabiano uh everything
went according to his plan
but yeah I was very lucky I told him
after the game now okay I'm very sorry
like normally I lose I lose but today
somehow he was unlucky just an
incredible defense you follow yeah I
today yeah I just found all the moves
and I didn't know any of this and um
normally I find such sequences only if
I've seen them before was this bishop to
A3 yeah the new idea at least or maybe
it's written down in a file but
the thing is what I played is a Backup
backup option I had some other things
but he move ordered me a little bit like
I think D4 I recollect this bishop B3
idea I think D4 order I don't recollect
now I realize more principles to go to
K8
in C6 but I started to um to doubt that
and then I realized I mean I knew the
technology 6 and transposed to my backup
line which I can play and then I knew
something like mb3 Bishop E6 I believe
and I think there's a game of Shanklin
against iron lamid yeah you know another
American against Dutch clash and and one
of your coaches as well yes of course
yeah so I knew that this is okay I'm
closely following Irvin's games and you
know I can always fall back on
everyone's games if you're out of book
but Bishop A3 I didn't know and then I
realized that okay Bishop six I'm gonna
get a worse version
and
um yeah I realized it's like I have to
solve the problems and sort of by
elimination I came to to the conclusion
I kind of underestimated because I was
counting on CD of course I understood my
original intention was to go Bishop E6
but then I realized that actually it's
very unpleasant because it simply takes
goes CD4 and I was thinking I'm gonna
double on the E5 when I realized I could
just play G3
something like win this queen E3 or
sequence and this position is really
really bad for me so then I realized
that okay the move must be D5
also because its position looks pretty
fine for black and I originally planned
to take on DC and then I realized that
if I take here first
um I can play Bishop F5 and the
difference is that after he takes place
rookie one I bring the queen right to
the seven not to d8 and then
I realized this is probably a better
order and here I thought maybe I can use
it with Knight takes E8 but then I saw
this I mean I understood that he won
circuit one because Queen City Bishop F5
and Queen Seven and I realized through
q1 Queen E1 and
okay you know you have these options
yeah this is the confidence is it just
like intuition what do you base your uh
yeah I think it's all the mocking over
the years I've become very good at
spotting Perpetual checks and all sorts
of different drawing patterns from all
the memes so
you know the mocking is rubbing off and
eventually um it helps it helps actually
and I think this was the last critical
moment right and you were sitting on
your hands and you were trying to kind
of visualize everything and finally you
weren't looking at the board and finally
you got up and played Queen yeah yes one
um
uh thought here
um I mean it's sort of clear that this
is a drawing line because I was looking
for a way for him to play on but it was
so artificial like bishopy too I mean it
is so incredibly artificial and I have
so many different ways I thought Bishop
G4 is good so the king of one distribute
is very bad I was I was thinking of one
was the critical yeah yeah and then I
think Bishop G4 was very good but also I
have such a margin at this point I mean
material is okay and the pawn 22 is
alive yeah so it was clear that he has
to do this D6 and then this pattern is
pretty simple so I'm speaking of that
moment I think we have it ready to uh
show on the live feed and maybe you can
walk us through what you were thinking
at this point
maybe I just fell asleep
okay
you thought for a while I think you were
in that position no no nobody's filming
you while you're sleeping and looking at
you afterwards
or slo-mo
we have slow mo yeah wow that's what you
want to show off hey you guys you want
to show off the technology of course
okay okay
no it's very awkward you know nobody's
filming you should film people when
they're eating or sleeping
um
as we all know so yeah very awkward
footage there but in the end I woke up
and you made the right decision found I
found my perpetually I'm very happy with
that big result big defense for you
tomorrow with the white pieces you have
to put on the pressure on your opponent
how are you going to approach that game
I play Yan yeah I always very well
prepared
as we see so far they of course had a
tough tough tournament and um yeah we'll
see I mean
I think it's gonna be an exciting game I
enjoy playing you know great players and
um
yeah very very interesting what to
happen because he's probably uh the best
prepared player in the world right now
he's done extensive preparation and we
saw in the match also his preparation
was um
probably better than uh
with a lot of ding curly preparation
wise he was getting better positions
with both colors then then ding so um
yeah it's uh it's always a challenge and
you know I really like players that are
well prepared as well because I see it's
a challenge too
try you know and find something
interesting
and the tournament in general is very
very exciting now I think I think
Fabiano is doing well I think there is
struggling today but he's of course he's
notorious for um
it's slippery yeah he's notorious for
getting more than what he deserves
but we'll see we'll see that's just a
quick look at this position just sure
yeah
yeah okay wow so now he's I'm not sure
he's getting the counter play you know I
saw his position here we were talking
with Fabiano he here and I was saying
that maybe you know here maybe it's not
as bad as it looks because why it's king
of course position like positionally it
looks like lost so I guess if it's an
end game like this might be lost a night
good night but Bishop everything but I
think I think the white king is uh could
potentially be weak because it cannot
find safety on the king side and I
thought H5 H4 was very strong I
underestimated this movie K5 but you see
here the computer is not hateful black
position and I think indeed because
after H5 I think if you move around it's
gonna jump a little bit so yes H5
Knight F3 yeah okay maybe yeah but I uh
I see
um potential for black to to get country
play certainly because I think the
whites King is a little uncomfortable
still what I don't like about Rook C7 of
course the evaluation is the primary
thought but the reason you can justify
the evaluation is I guess
um
I guess you want to keep material on the
board because I imagine
um if the white king finds itself
somewhere on ditzel
after let's say eventually I just test
for argument's sake
um in an eventual scenario where you
trade the
the Rooks in some way yeah just to
maybe in a position like that even here
you know C5 is good but maybe in a
position like this you want to have one
more look there on the queen side to
bother the king yeah but uh yeah all
very concrete I understand that there is
a idea behind Rook C7 because with that
he trades off why it's only active piece
and The Rook was exerting pressure on
the F7 in the lines of 9395 it was it
was a thing so maybe he thinks okay
we'll get rid of The Rook and then we
will get some action but there are very
little pieces uh you know let's see H5
is probably an idea
again Knight F3 now 95 is coming and
another thing he could have in mind and
that's very common theme in such thing
in such cases to trade uh like that and
very often because the king is
disturbing the roof from entering the
game very often in position like this
white loses one of the Pawns
because they're getting attacked you
would love to be able to cast along yeah
or break The Rook across but here it
seems that you're good because after
Bishop C2 there is this tactical
resource it should be three rugby one
yeah and if rookie 8 yeah somehow maybe
this is what he missed because King E2
doesn't actually work can you get
checked on C4 oh imagine missing Castle
move 24. that could be the case uh
because yeah this stuff it's not working
I mean it's not working you it is close
but it's just not quite quite working
yeah we'll we'll see he's very slippery
as I mentioned oh G4 is an interesting
positional idea I like this G4 move this
is what Fabi was mentioned as well
killing the knight uh killing the Knight
yes but
hard to say I still felt you know with
two Rooks let's see now the move like in
YouTube is easier to make because
there's not one more Rook on the queen
side with more pieces with morooks
you're afraid that the truck would be
active and your king in the center will
get in some trouble but uh you know done
that against others I just yet he's
he's a very very um
he's one of those players who is always
lucky to the point that you start
wondering maybe it's not just luck and
it's it's a very different brand of
chairs it's not a computer chess like
his games with engineer if you I think
if you check his scent upon uh you know
analysis the he plays very bad idea I
think he's uh yeah I think he's playing
objective quotes you know in in
quotation marks because
um chess is you know it's not played by
computers and he plays this brand of
chess
similar like Hikaru where it looks as
though he makes a lot of bad moves
because engines don't approve them but
humans tend to
see the point behind his ideas he plays
this human chess and
he's selling a lot of
a lot of stuff to his opponents and
opponents are buying it yeah you know so
I think he might sell something to to do
that here but we'll see he's never had
such a bad position so far in the
tournament so we'll see uh we'll see
what happens Ali Raza definitely a good
uh Merchant so thank you very much for
giving us your insights and giving the
guys in St Louis A Commentary break so I
will let you go we'll let you get ready
for tomorrow's match and we'll see you
tomorrow thank you guys back to you
thank you Christian thank you Anish
commentator break indeed
takes our job thank you very much for
that now you talk about the pond
grubbers Association and grabbing upon
well this is what Duda has done he's
played a lot of Tempe moves uh and he's
left his King potentially vulnerable but
the problem is is you've got to break
open the position you got to get your
pieces into play and a lot of blacks
breaks whether they be E5 or C5 or
stopped and that was why we saw the move
H5 by alireza he's trying to get towards
White's King in order to show
compensation I think now see the reason
why we kind of rejected H5 on our side
of the of the pond was because after H5
we were a little bit more afraid of the
move Knight F3 we were beginning to warm
up to the computer's idea of G4 because
if we get a knight to E5 wait a minute
we've got a pause yeah I mean it looks
like to me like White's the one at doing
the attacking and what does it look like
for you VAR I mean if white gets to play
Knight F3 and E5 before anything happens
to his King he's just better much better
even before that there was an inaccurate
move uh bad move Rook C7 but this last
move H5 is allowing the Knight to go to
F3 E5 with the really nice Advantage for
white here but let's take a look uh
first at that move Rook C7 we go back
couple of moves so in this position
actually uh after the move
Rook takes Ace yeah right here in this
position he had to continue with the
idea of a very important in this
position to play this move G4 you really
want to take away this Knight F3 option
so let's say if you take on A7 and you
want to have more Rooks on a board here
you play the move H5
and there's it's not as easy here to
continue for why there's still some
danger here small Advantage for white in
this position you do have to play this
move King E2 which is important to move
here to connect and bring this Rook into
the game here but there there are some
chances here for black in this position
Rook C7 move is is quite passive in this
position and now after this capture here
he
he takes takes and here again I think
this G4 was a very important move to try
to prevent the knight from coming in but
white is already significant
significantly better after this Rook C7
idea here but now H5 Knight F3 I'm not
sure what is he going to do now after
this move because Knight is going to
reach the E5 Square it's going to be
very very active Bishop G6 is his best
move allowing the move 95 and then try
to look for some opportunities maybe
after the move Queen ba try to exchange
coins
but here actually white doesn't even
want to trade Queens can play the move
Queen to E7 activating the queen now
attacking the pawn on G5 and if you
capture let's say on B2
this would be the right time for castle
castle move 24 with a completely winning
position now black king is really weak
G5 is hanging Knight is very strong once
this Rook comes in into the game the
game is going to be over here
and guys we have a repetition in an mvl
game looks like he doesn't see any
opportunities in this game and they've
been repeating like Bishop E6 Bishop F1
and I thought he would try to push a
little bit in this position try to maybe
get some chance but uh
they have repeated two times and now
uh let's see uh could be our fourth draw
the round yes could be our Bishop F1
Bishop C4 I see that they have been
repeating and I think
yes he might
be three here yeah Knight B3 is the best
option here if he wants to play for a
win he should try to play the move
Knight B3 uh if he plays Bishop perform
after Bishop E6 it will just beat robot
doesn't look like I don't know just uh
doesn't look like unveil things he has
anything in this position at least and
again there is no reason if you're gonna
play on there is no reason to repeat so
many times in my opinion you repeat one
time especially Jack is known to get
into time travel here yeah and there it
is and I think we're gonna see the the
handshake now after the you know Bishop
Bishop B6 yeah so four draws so far well
I'm still kind of uh I I'm shaken not
stirred about the result between Fabi
and Anisha not that the game wasn't a
perfect game and a drawn all that but
just this idea that uh he started with
90 minutes and he finished with 95. I
mean I don't think
Bobby's ever done that in his career you
know like he had much more time on his
clock when than when he started with
because so much well everything as it
turned out was actually
you don't get extra points for uh for
for having more time on the clock at the
end of the game a little bit unlucky
that Anish took his time and found you
know every correct move here just to
make the draw and force a draw and he
couldn't uh you know use that extra one
hour on the clock well let's just remind
everybody once again that fabi's in the
Dugout he's already got his draw he's a
plus two he's going into the next round
tomorrow leaving us with one game the
game of Duda farusia so obviously this
the stage is set go ahead for ruja show
us why you're the grand Chester Champion
defeat one of the players who's having a
poor result
except Duda didn't is not following
script he's got his own ideas uh with
this uh we're anticipating mvl and dioc
being drawn right and in that case we'll
have four draws today and we'll have one
game left between Duda and ferocious
with everything to play for however
our Judgment of the position is that
Duda with the extra Pawn in the pocket
and pretty safe King I mean after all I
mean your pieces are on h8 and d8 how
threatening could they possibly be extra
upon on the conversation extra pawn and
compensation is Roman jinji Villi
will tell us Knight F3 to 95 and
again you know will will be threatening
Queen takes F7 with Nate to be delivered
very shortly so it sure feels like big
Advantage for uh Duda at this point I do
believe we have more tweets we might
take a chance to be surprised by our
audience as you're welcome to join the
conversation you can ask any questions
you would like this one comes from
mntl snacks uh question is many people
underestimate the physical impact of
long chess games how do you balance the
physical and mental aspects of the game
well as a competitor yourself playing in
these women's championships winning them
you know that it does require a lot of
physical conditioning tell us about it
absolutely when you're playing five six
sometimes seven hour games every single
day
it's exhausting it is absolutely
exhausting and some tournaments are
quite long nine rounds 11 13 Even so you
have to be really in good physical shape
and should you have to be able to get
good night's sleep every night without
it oh man yeah without that
so you talk about your physical
endurance what do you do do you
gym do you walk yes wait left bodybuild
uh I'm somewhat a gym addict yes a gym
rat yes I've been weightlifting for the
last four years now I was being
facetious
they're not going to challenge you
anymore actually it's funny I have
personal trainers at the gym but I don't
have a chess coach
like that tells it all right there and a
physical handshake
uh between these two uh Grandmasters as
they make a draw uh VAR uh you know
yourself very well uh the the
requirements of professional chess your
energy levels have to be really good
which requires that you are in shape or
you have you need endurance absolutely
yeah so you need to be in good shape to
perform well to you know do well under
pressure especially if you have this
long game sometimes you have five six
hour games and in a long tournament so
you need to be in good shape whether you
go to the gym you lift or you do some
other sports another thing it's very
important to have a good diet I think
during this tournaments to make sure you
have all your energy I absolutely agree
with Nazi about sleep you really need to
sleep you need to have a good routine to
get your eight nine hours of sleep in
order to perform well and I think Magnus
mentioned that in one of his interviews
if you cannot sleep well you're not
going to be able to play that well so
you know that's one thing he does he
slips in so definitely you need all that
and you need to be in good shape to
perform well these days in the
tournaments exactly so definitely to the
viewers question you know that balance
has to be addressed and in my day I just
want to say that swimming in tennis were
the top
sports of the grand Masters for
draws already in this penultimate round
Championship round round eight and
tomorrow everything to be decided but
one game for all the marbles another
tweet before we return to the game
and this one says
drum roll this is from
Paolo Thomas from Twitter
uh yesterday Nazi said that she learned
E4 as her first opening move actually no
I learned different D4 I have any tips
on developing an opening repertoire so I
think that's a very important question
right everybody wants to know anything
to clarify what I said was that most
players learn E4 and with black E5 as
their first opening repertoire exactly
but somehow I was taught D4 first move
as an opening repertoire and I think I
missed out on all the classical openings
of Roy Lopez and Italian and all this
fried liver attacks man you know Max
Lang attacks that's what I'm talking
about yeah so I think for children or
anyone uh just starting to learn
openings playing all the classical
openings will teach you a lot about the
game exactly yeah exactly uh coach tips
how do you how do you what do you
recommend how do you develop an opening
repertoire what is an opening repertoire
uh opening reperto RS when you're
starting the game you need to know which
moves to play you know so for example
when you're starting chess you're really
new to the game I think it's much better
to start out with the move E4 I myself
also started with the move d4 and became
a lifelong D4 player so and also missed
out in a lot of the fun statelium
positions rui Lopez's and other other
openings it's very hard later in a
career to make a change for example I
remember Levon aronian switched to E4
after being a D4 player for a very very
long time just having an opening
repertoire knowing some openings and in
the beginning you don't have to know
them really deeply I would say maybe the
first 10 moves just to know where the
pieces go and that would be very
important when you're playing a game you
have some ideas get the pieces out make
sure your castle and get a reasonable
position where you can play your middle
game
all right very good thank you for that
thank you for your questions to our
audience shout out always nice to know
where we should be yeah ask you yes sir
uh are you E40 I know you're a C4 player
right were you always no on the contrary
E4 was my go-to I loved E4 because I
learned all of the bad I had all the bad
habits of Scholastics chess players
which included the Italian the two
knights defense the max language attack
I left for them I thought they were the
greatest fun uh the gambits the Danish
get all the stuff I just love that uh
later my opponents weren't quite as
obliging they were doing things like
Sicilian dragons and all kinds of
offbeat openings and defenses and I soon
discovered that E4 was really really
hard to play especially against people
who specialize in certain defenses like
just take the Scandinavian defense right
Gary kasparra faced the Scandinavian
defense in his world championship match
against Vichy didn't come out with an
advantage of made a draw well that was
quite a shock for the world of Chess and
the scandinative in defense is viable at
the highest level at the lowest levels
of amateur you know somebody who's well
prepared in the Scandinavian defense and
you're not studying the Scandinavian
defense is white it's not easy to get a
defense
so E4
became harder and harder for me to play
as I struggled to get into let's say the
a
and a space more well prepared Upon Us
exactly so I said oh my God I can't do
this anymore and I Look to just play
solid readies Knight F3 G3 Bishop G2 and
then I learned some foxy move openings
with C4 and I was trying to avoid the
great depths of theories and uh yeah it
was just it was just so much harder to
play E4 let's just jump back into the
game for just a moment because after the
move H7 H5 I this was a move I didn't
even consider it helped me out here and
now see I mean I was so focused
singularly I want to say you know I'm
seeing you know H4 and G or G4 and H4
ideas or H4 and G4 ideas so exclusively
I want to stop whatever it is my
opponent is trying to do I want to stop
unless it's really bad then I want to
encourage to continue I was so focused
on Knight F3
because
95 and queen takes F7 is as natural as a
baby smile and the move b2b3 that is
just a move that whoa whoa what does
that have to do with what's going on
um isn't yeah this is an opportunity for
maybe G4 and H4 now for maybe do that a
little bit he had one hour on the clock
he could have really taken his power
what is the clock Times by the way uh
right now Duda has 50 minutes and feruja
20 26. okay so a two to one time Edge uh
actually in favor of Duda b2b3 I
understand this is a kind of a passing
move and simultaneously it's a move that
says my queen side's a little bit
safer I guess uh but does this give
farrugia a chance to climb back into the
game bar absolutely now feruja is back
in a game here he needs to play this
move G4 right so it's really strange
decision to play the move B3 and uh he
do that took he had about an hour on the
clock he took about 10 minutes he did
it's not like he rushed this move but
again the the idea of Knight F3 Knight
E5 is just so natural that you really
want to activate this Knight here first
after the move B3 uh black is back in
the game here but there is a very
specific idea you need to find here so I
will show you now guys okay what
furition is the first thing he needs to
do immediately he got a second chance
here to play the smooth G4 to make sure
you just completely uh kill this Knight
here because Knight has no good scores
to go to now and it's going to take a
long time to maneuver this but the
reason maybe uh he's thinking a little
bit because after this King E2 you have
a very specific idea you have to do here
because you really don't have any pawn
breaks or it doesn't look like you have
any any Contra play here you can't even
you cannot even trade queens now because
the Rook is coming into the game the end
game is Just winning but the only move
that gives a good counter play here is
the move H4
which it's not very natural because now
you're trading more pieces and it seems
like this end game looks like should be
just lost but after Queen takes H4 you
have incredible compensation because of
this queen coming in now to H1 and then
coming on this first Rank and suddenly
this king is very very uncomfortable
here so I was looking at this position
trying to make this work because uh by
looking at the position it seems like
it's very safe now you have the queen on
a great Square here you got this a pawn
going through but black is in time now
to get a contra play with Queen H1
yeah
you take the C part now you have two
connected pass pawns Queen takes G2 I'm
coming back to the C7 to control this
diagonal and now again the smooth Queen
H1 comes in
and uh it's it's very difficult to make
progress here let's see if you just try
to advance the pawn what happens if you
just play the move A4 just try to to
push this Pawn so here uh you can play
the move Queen A1
and you can't really do much here you
can really move the Knight here let's
say A5 for sure maybe
King G6
just waiting
B5 let's go B4 oh pardon me B4 let's go
yeah now as soon as you play before I
have this move Queen A3 now now this
should be three comes in in two plays oh
no and now you could be in serious
trouble you need some moves like E4 and
after E4 we know it's gonna be lots of
lots of control play here no I can't I
can't allow you Queen A3 Queen A3 is too
strong so you can't play B4 and the
question is now how do you make progress
here you can't move the king can't
really move this pawns it doesn't want
to allow people to C2 either I can't
play Queen B6 and you know uh escort my
Pawn maybe Queen C5 guys you can play
Queen C5 try to keep things under
control but then suddenly there is some
Contra play now coming in with the G3
and if you capture
Bishop GeForce check no I'm I'm afraid
yeah it's yeah it's getting very risky
King D3 I mean I have repetition already
here too but actually black is winning
after Queen E1 and then the bishop F5
thread not a surprise so uh again very
very dangerous Contra play here but
alireza needs to find the smooth G4 and
follow it up with H4 after he plays G4 I
think he will play H4 because that's the
only point of putting the Rook on AJ
here to try to get some counter play on
each file well as a niche said in his
interview is a process of elimination
that he went for the most direct talk
talk Queen takes E1 and I think it's
through the process of elimination where
as you look at this exact position for
for from Black's point of view and you
go well I can't play C5 I can't play for
E5 the immediate H4 is not that
attractive because if she takes H1 or
that really leaves G4 followed by H4 is
my only source
firosha played
which I rejected I rejected H4 because
of G takes okay let's see is this idea
that he's got to take back with the pawn
right this is not what you that's not
upon sacrifice that you want to do so
farouza is thinking that he's going to
play Queen G5 and maybe tickle this but
this is this is a dream necessity that I
I wanted to make that move on the
previous turn followed by Knight E5
and uh VAR my first impression is bad
timing by farugia's H4 is that correct
absolutely yeah sir again it just it
seems like wow he is not very
comfortable perhaps he doesn't have so
much experience in this kind of position
um you really need to avoid this idea
stop this idea Knight f395 and he just
played H4 which you know you would play
in you know maybe different type of
positions you can play this but in this
position now white just takes on H4 and
I will show you now it's a big Advantage
for white now just a big Advantage yeah
g takes H4 you play GTX H4 and once
again we see the move Knight F3 coming
in now you're putting pressure on H4 and
now you have this Knight E5 move
available and I'm not sure what is his
idea exactly what is he planning to do
here because uh G4 looks so so good
compared to the smooth H4 what if Bishop
E4 maybe bishop E4 here
and Knight E5 attacking on F7 Queen F6
then I just have this really nice F3 oh
just simply F3 kicks the bishop back
stops any attacks on Jesus Bishop goes
back to G6 I can even tuck in my king
now on F2 very safe and just just few
more moves just to consolidate and this
is I think this is just close to be
winning this position oh my uh well what
I wanted to say is that fobby's in the
Dugout having made an early draw but
that could work out brilliantly if Duda
was to oblige dinners on me says uh Fabi
to the Polish Grandmaster but remember
what Anish said don't count firusha out
his as I understand he's one of the
luckiest players so maybe that it's not
always line his way back into this game
right as he's put as he tries to put
pressure but I don't know Knight F3 to
Knight E5 sure looks very very
compelling to me as uh just before we go
on our break where we just want to
remind everyone body of the results thus
far
right we have for us MB
against Geary and the publisher again so
all drugs all draws with one game
remaining due to furusia we urge our
audience with only one game for us to
come into a farm help us out send us
your tweets question our experts uh
panels what is what questions you have
and we'll look to address them on the
other side of the break be back shortly
[Music]
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we view
chess as a valuable educational tool
learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
over the roughly one and a half
millennium
existence chess has been known as a tool
of military strategy a metaphor for
human affairs
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
thank you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage of round Eight's prevent
chess classic now see we have four games
in the history books right we have four
very exciting results four dress four
draws and we still have one game going
today against Garuda well one man who's
very happy is Fabby as he goes in The
Jug out with a half a point lead over
farugia at the moment everything depends
on the outcome of that game let's take a
look at Bobby's line score and how he
found himself in the leadership but
first of all pardon me uh tomorrow I'm
gonna explain one of his uh
opponents was chasing him a richer
report very very important pursuer you
could say because he might say this
outcome depend could determine first
place sorry and in between that we can
see Richard has one win three losses and
six draws so probably is feeling pretty
confident and now his aligned score
undefeated undefeated very solid
tournament with plus two scores yeah
those abrasive wins in rounds three and
four propelled them uh these last few
draws it just feels like Fabio is on I
mean he really LED farugia off the hook
that could have been the
Clincher if you will also if you
remember in the first game he had a very
good chance against diac that he also
could not convert exactly position all
right well uh as we see there's uh the
uh one remaining a game on stage as uh
Jana Duda is sitting there looking at
his position he's saying how am I going
to bring home the full point here and
how should he bring home the full point
bar
uh it's not so easy actually yes sir
evaluation is pretty big it's like plus
one and a half but for example the best
move in this position is to move a force
A4 yes you have to be careful moving
this knight from F3 because if you play
the move 95 that was gonna allow the
move Queen G5
and black is going to get a counter play
in fact 95 is a blunder after Queen G5
it's already equal
in fact the take us through that because
you know I would find myself drawn to 95
Queen G5 castles and I understand I'm
putting my king in danger like right
like extreme danger but my reasoning is
my reasoning being you can't play Bishop
E4 I go Queen F7 and H3 I'm ready to
play G3 so maybe my king is safe
actually if Castle H3 your only move
after H3 in this position you ask her
not to lose his G4 only that wouldn't
have been my first decision I would want
to play G3 on a if you play G3 the
problem of is is because I have this
move Queen F5
curiouser and curiouser no I mean what
is that move dude I'm getting Queen E4
and queen G2 mate uh which is why you
want G4 okay I'll fall for it go back a
moment and I'll play G4 and I'll still
make the pretension hey give me the
moves King H2 and F4 my king is safe
yeah now actually black can continue two
different ways even here but the best
yeah you can play Rook H4 but the more
direct way to make a draw is H2 King H1
the safety and now again two options you
have here but let's go over this one the
more direct one Rook H3 what's the idea
of Rook H3 right I'm still I'm still
confused myself okay uh Nasi wants to
know what's the idea of Rook H3 so let's
say you play Queen C7 right logical move
you just bring the queen into the game
it's kind of a defensive move I've got
Knight G6 on tap when I'm get really
frightened yes so again it's it's a
complicated position different options
you have here you have a move Queen F6
but let's move C5 now
trying to weaken the position of the
night here
let's say you capture yeah let's say
catch now another pound sacrifice
is this for real are you pulling our
legs what is it no I I'm also a little
shocked myself but it looks like it's
just it's uh it's gonna work out somehow
so okay
okay I understand if I take with the
pawn queen F4 is a little dangerous I'm
beginning to feel like Bishop E4 check
is a very soon winning for black exactly
you can't take now on D4 I mean at some
point you probably want to take on G6
just try to liquidate sure it's a
logical take and now the only move that
holds the game is Queen D5 check
forcing you to play the move F3 okay and
then Rook takes F3
and I don't have Queen E5 Rook takes uh
F3 Queen F3 check King H2 and uh yeah we
can just play Queen F1
if you go King H1 just Queen F1 and if
you go King to uh H3 again uh Queen
three check if you play Queen G3
is
Queen H1 check
what an amazing it's a very complex line
I agree crazy okay but go back to the
current position for a moment of our 95.
again you might call it a blunder I call
it uh attractive you go Queen G5 now
castles I admit that's a little bit you
know I'm being my provocative worst King
F1 just defend the pawn the problem is
after the move Queen G5 the very next
move is going to be Queen F5 okay and
suddenly this queen is getting access to
the B1 and C2 Square I hear you but I
I'm I'm I'm on my again on my track
shoes uh my walking shoes and I go King
G1 and I just slide across the board on
a good day Rook F3 H3 B1 check nobody
appreciates my Brilliance King H2 now
Queen C2 and now you have some problems
with this F2 Pawn oh the send it Rook F1
Rook F1
and now we go back now to this idea of
H3 we can't argue with the engines we
just can't it's disgusting and then if
you play G3 gas or the same Queen E4
idea comes into play I knew you had that
in mind I just knew it oh my goodness so
we have to start immediately with what
the move Knight E5 is not a trap yeah
maybe we should start with King F1
Juan is one of the top moves here to
play yes you need this Knight on F3 okay
very important and oftentimes we see
that we still play this move King F1 to
run away with your idea and also just to
protect the G2 pawns so King F1 is one
of the best moves here
uh here's I think alireza's idea is
pretty clear he's going to play the move
Queen F6 okay and now he's threatening
some H3 ideas because you cannot just
capture F3 Knight is hanging here
so Queen C7
now you you will be very happy to play
the move Queen E5 here and get rid of
this queen it's true yeah so this is
something you really want to do
um and now again H3 you have to continue
with this move
and if Queen E5
if you play Queen E5 now Bishop D3 check
this is yeah this is not easy guys
Bishop D3 check
qg1 and now just positional move
positional move Bishop to E4 setup for
white here exactly you would think that
this should be game over favor of White
Queen G3 and G3 Queen G3 there's a queen
G6
well Rook takes H3 what am I missing
Rook takes H3
I think
it takes H3 Queen side Pawns
but I'm up two queen takes H3 generous
and give one Bishop takes F3 I think
we're losing F3 actually I think you're
losing both pawns yes sir check
and I said I would be generous not not
that you're not excessively generous and
you have this F2 Pawn hanging that's why
you don't have time to at least try to
get the C Pawn so you have four on three
here so I think this is uh very likely
to be a draw again the very difficult
lines to navigate you know in my opinion
here wow but uh at least do that is
thinking right now
and the clock times of the two players
uh now right they still have uh plenty
of time Duda has 30 minutes
and 17 moves
despite his extreme youth I do note that
uh very mature alireza just does use a
lot of his clock and it's not unusual to
see him a bit behind
on uh time uh on the clock yes sir I
want to jump in show you one more line
here actually analyze this a little bit
before and just forgot to show you the
move A4 as I was mentioning the top move
here is a logical move here you want to
advance this Pawn here one of the key
lines here is there is a C5 move here
it's very complicated move here but I
wanted to show you this queen F6 that I
I looked at at this idea Queen F6 right
uh now you play the move Queen C7 very
logical you want to trade Queens yeah
and now Queen E5 doesn't work any longer
because you have the queen E5 check and
you're just simply winning now points
will come afterwards so so the only idea
now is to play the move H3
okay and here you play the move Queen F4
not Queen E5 but queen of Queen F4 yes
you're trying to trade queens and this
takes away the pressure from the F3
Knight here so we're not
we're nothing takes F4 yeah we have to
take the queen first because if we take
immediately Queen F6 and then we lose
the Rook here so we take on F4
Pawn takes F4
if we take on G2 then simply Rook h8
King takes and a very important move
here needs to be played here guys you
can't just push the pawn because the
bishop will come in to play on D3 right
so you play the move King D3 to prevent
that and now you're getting ready to
push the a pawn and um this is this is a
very big Advantage for white this end
game most likely you will lose this Pawn
later on in the game I can play Knight
G1 F3 and bring the king in so this is
this is a winning game uh for for white
so he he does need to play this move A4
but not an easy move to play I think in
this position here King F1 is one option
A4 is the best and that's the one we'll
give him the most winning chances here
for Duda
thank you VAR just uh struggling uh here
we are we've got all the tools we need
including the chess engines and it's
tough even for us to navigate these
lines I see it a little Grimace there by
dudas he's in there you know trying to
decipher a riddle here what is these
for me the move A2 A4 is not an
intuitive move right I kind of think
I've got these trumps I'm going to use
them in any king of Pawn end game you
bet but I want to neutralize what I see
as some vague threats on the king side
you know H3 Bishop E4 I want to play
moves like Rook H3 I want to play moves
I don't care like King F1
95. so rather than using my trumps
immediately with the move A4 and Rook H3
uh it's a very human move in duda's mind
he is now ready to play the move Knight
E5 followed by Rook F3 and how do you do
uh ready to pounce on the F7 Pawn so
Rook H3 makes uh a lot of sense the
reason I didn't want to offer it is
because the queen side pawns are so
vulnerable with the Rook when the when
the Rook was on H1 we could go King D2
and Rook A1 not with the Rook on H3 are
we going to lose one of the pots let's
imagine that Queen A8 shows up on the
board because that's the most that's the
first uh move that you would into it
right now we've been looking at
variations where where black is getting
pressure so the idea of trading Queens
might at first come as a relief until
you kind of look at the position a
little bit more I assume I don't want to
see Rook A2 rookie two yeah so A4 four
The Rook B8 or Bishop C2 right either
one of those two things uh Knight comes
Bishop C2
and this looks like just a drawing we
can't pick up the pawn on H4 but if we
lose both being and a then of course it
was nothing to talk about right here it
takes can we keep the
agent yes that was it's just very
unfortunately
true that
um
uh once again in case this game does end
in a drawing we might be racing towards
a draw what happens in case of the
playoffs right tomorrow we might have a
playoff if two players are tied there
will be a two game rapid match with 15
minutes with and 10 second increment
right but there can also be a three
three player tie and in that case we'll
have rapid round robin with 10 minutes
and 5 Second increment if the players
are still tight we'll have our favorite
Armageddon game with five minutes for
white four for black and two second
increment from move 61 and the key thing
about Armageddon is that draw goes to
Black
and
to accommodate the potential of a
playoff scenario the games will all the
the round tomorrow I want to say will
begin one hour early ER so our broadcast
will be uh starting an hour earlier uh
good morning St Louis
um Rook H3
might be Frankly Speaking a little bit
too defensive VAR and the fact of the
matter is that this move Queen A8 may
just
take away White's Advantage uh yes
absolutely Rook HD is not the best move
and uh after Queen 8 which I think is
the best move for black we can get into
an end game with four versus three
and I will show you the key line here
Will
but let's go to Romania with two
Christians
well just to jump on on this game really
quick I think Rook H3 is sure not an
engine approved move but it's a human
move
um and I will explain to you why for
example if you don't play Rook H3 the
problem is Black's plan is quite clear
I'm going to go Queen to F6 and after
that so for example let's say you start
with A4 which is uh the best move
according to the engine I will go Queen
to F6 and now after Queen to C7 once
again we're following the main Engine
line the problem is you have to contend
from afar visualize from afar this
opening of the position once the G2 and
H3 nowadays Pawn get exchange you will
have a lot of weaknesses on the light
squares so despite the fact that the
engine manages to defend uh accurately
and effortlessly from a humorous
perspective it's very difficult to allow
this Pawn trade so that's why I think
Rook to H3 after a very long uh time
spent by Duda was at the move made and
hear me out for a second sure I
understand that after Queen to A8 the
computer is saying that black maybe has
gotten closer to equalizing the position
or at least getting stirring the game
into more Peaceful Waters but the
problem is
Queen 28 I'm seeing this position I'm
saying this position as white and I'm
saying that we're going to get the 4
versus 3 but also we're going to get an
imbalance in terms of Knight versus
Bishop so this is going to be a very
long Grind from a psychological
perspective from a humorous perspective
whenever you see these type of positions
in which you're not risking anything as
white you're very much drawn to a
playing this line forget about allowing
black to go H3 and opening up the
position giving a task to the bishop on
G6 to roam around the light squares
around my Kim I don't want to see any of
that in if I'm in duda's place I want to
start the game towards a more Peaceful
Waters in which I can grind down my
opponent and take a look at this for
example Queen 28 By the way is on the
board Queen takes a through takes A8 but
once we get into this position sure I'll
give you the A2 Pawn you'll get the B3
pawn and we're going to have four versus
three but once again Knight versus
Bishop I'm going to have a beautiful
night right on E5 I'm going to slowly
push my pawns on the king side G4 G5
this is not easy this is going to be a
very difficult position to defend for
alireza but we know and Anish has
mentioned it as well he is slippery and
this is exactly what he will be focused
on trying to defend this one trying to
be resilient and trying to keep Pace
with Fabiano caruana going into the
final round but it's not going to be
easy
thank you for that uh Christian
absolutely uh well former world champion
Magnus Carlson himself said in an
interview anytime you can get a position
where you have two results
one in your favor or Draw in the hand
that's already
a big result we didn't see your
prescription however we did not see Rook
takes uh H4 followed by 95 in fact what
we saw was the immediate A4 and well for
alireza that made things pretty darn
simple gotta Play Bishop C2
gotta take away the base Pawn so I can
capture both pawns on the queen side and
well and white still pick up C6 somehow
let's say white goes Knight E5 all right
gift meet upon
ah just a second let me just pause here
because sorry uh I did not consider F6
uh and maybe I should be considering F6
uh jury's still out for me let's say I
fall for it I take the pump
uh Rook takes age
okay I'll fall for it I'll take a pop
I hope I'm not getting checkmates
exactly I don't think you are I'm not
going to Checkmate you but I might be
the same yeah but I might be disturbing
right like okay check
King which way should I go E2 F3 or well
there is the king E2 let's say I think
King E2 is just fine that being the case
let me hamper you uh with the move
Bishop C4 so that I can give you a check
and another check
so you have
Rook idea immediate as well I didn't
want to tell you about that one don't
don't don't tell Nasi that was my plan
yeah I don't know how
going to get out of this without giving
up the F2 Pawn yeah this well I mean I'm
a pond down but I feel like I've got
certain initiative I don't like this
movie for VAR I I think that that kind
of spoils it but you've got uh something
completely different on your board yeah
I'm analyzing a little bit deeper even
if you get both pawns back there's still
some problems in this position that I
was analyzing let me show you how I got
here first guys okay
so after the move Bishop C2
and we play the move 95.
and our Bishop takes B3
Rook takes H4 and now you take back with
a bishop okay if you wanna you wanna
just hang on to the C6 Pawn as well here
in this case Rook G4 comes in first you
can't go to the H file you're going to
drop the F7 Pawn if you go to F6 Rook F4
so your only move is here to play the
move King f8 and now we play the move
Rook F4 annoying putting pressure on F7
and yeah if you play the move F5 then
you're in big trouble after the move
G-Force clear and if you play Bishop C2
I actually played the move G5 then it's
a very very strong pass Pawn I can go
back Rook H4 Rook H6 and this should be
a winning end game
so that's why you have to play the move
here Rook A7
in this position to protect uh F7 here
and I really like this idea to try to
fix this so make sure you can't really
play the move uh F6 so G4
now King G7 comes in now black is
considering to play the move F6 so we
play the move G5
and now it's very important for y for
black to bring this bishop into the game
so Bishop C2 comes in to try to control
this diagonal and even here there are
some chances here Rook F6
you can really go Bishop G6 in this end
game is because after Knight G6 E6 is
hanging The Rook C7 you have to defend
very passively this position
I mean we don't even have an extra point
I'm having trouble I believe in that why
it's better here yeah admirable
restraint and not capturing the pawn on
C6 sorry Barb please and the Knight only
five is so strong putting pressure on C6
and you're you're really stuck in this
position you might be able to somehow
hold by staying on this diagonal with
the bishop but very unpleasant because
you don't have the C5 option I will take
dc5 and one idea I would love to do is
get my king to C5 but I think what's
gonna happen is you're going to wait on
this diagonal and every time I try to
play the move King C3 only then you're
gonna play the move C5 so that's why we
see evaluation it's not increasing here
because King C3 then we have the strong
move C5 otherwise King B4 King C5 I
think that would be close to the winning
position here right
so yeah this is the current position 22
minutes for Duda uh 17 for firusha here
uh Advantage for white but still uh
chances for fioruja to hold this
position right thank you VAR and there
was a moment there when Nasi and I were
playing this position I think we were
looking at after Bishop C2 Rook takes H4
or hold on was it 95 yes 95 95 and I was
a little bit
um hesitant because I was considering
the move F7 F6 because I was afraid of
falling into what you were showing a
position where there was some positional
grip uh but does f is F6 okay F6 is not
as good and there is a concrete idea
guys because of the move Knight D7 and
the point is now you want to bring the
Knight to C5 so if I take the pawn you
take the pawn I fork you and I'm gonna
pick up that important A6
so you you have to take the pawn now 96
check if you go King G6 I just take the
opponent H4 then this end game I think I
have excellent chances to win because
the bonds are very weak and if King S7 I
go back Knight F4 Knight is very well
placed and uh Bishop B5 now you're ready
actually to start activating your Rook
with Rook A1 so it's very important not
to take immediately because Rook A1 Rook
A2 is going to be very very annoying
giving checks so you have to play the
move F3 first here nice so and now if
Rook A1 check
you play King D2
it's all about the pawn Islands why it
has one Pond Island and black yes okay
two checks that's exactly it King City
we gotta give up this Pawn actually Rook
80 but the king is gonna get really
active and now after Rook takes E3 Rook
H4 and this end game is actually just
simply hopeless here because Google H7
is coming up the king is already there
if we take the Rooks off the board it's
also winning so
this even though equal material on the
board but this is just the losing end
game for black fascinating what's more
important openings or endings endings as
you can see very very nicely uh
demonstrated there uh love it for thank
you very much for that also because we
have only one game remaining uh any uh
chances of joining the conversations now
is a very very good opportunity as uh in
the past we don't get a chance to read
out all the tweets that we do receive
and how can they join the conversation
you can send us your Twitter
store and you can also use YouTube and
Twitches live chats to send us your
question on St Louis chess club Channel
and it's a real challenge for you guys
to stump the Masters uh because we are
in fighting trim and we are disciplined
we are physically
mentally tough we have the endurance
we can handle all your questions
um
your overall I mean you you know you're
a player you're you're you're your
competitor you're you sit there and you
feel that white it's good but is it
enough
honestly I'm I'm pretty pessimistic when
it comes to my games in this position I
wouldn't be absolutely confident no I
would be hoping that I can convert this
but I think uh draw is more likely
result even here in this game I was most
impressed because really the move I
found the move F7 F6 attractive just
because of what pharah was saying you're
going to take on H4 you're going to play
Rook f4 on a good day you're going to
put a Pawn on G5 and I feel myself in a
vice where I'm getting squeezed and you
know I I feel uncomfortable so this idea
of F7 F6 I felt was compelling and I was
not anticipating this uh I I mean it's
not spectacular but it's a really fine
absolutely and it shows how even in the
end games with just few pieces on the
board you can miss so many tactical
ideas it's a beautiful one you take away
the E6 Bond and that's kind of the heart
and soul of a Black's position then then
things start falling off the board the
H4 Pawn the Knight is so nice on the F4
square and even if you end up winning
one of White's pawns back the the much
more active pieces the king asbar showed
got to C5 the Knight on that fourth
we're coming that is a really harmonious
configuration but to see the move Knight
D7 from afar not easy a2a4 Bishop C2 on
the board again I just tell me the clock
times it's not so easy for me they put
it in like equal now yeah they put it in
like four type yeah they both have about
17 minutes okay so equalizing on the
clock right and I think if Duda wants to
play for more than a drill he has to go
for this 95 Rook H4 and I'm pretty sure
he's going to do that if he plays
something like 92 then it'll be very
easy for black to equal exactly Munch
Bunch uh 95 rookies again forgetting
about the engine for a second VAR just
you know like you're competitive your
experience would tell you that White's
better clear but uh would you feel
absolutely confident you could bring
home the full point as white in this
position
um I would be very happy to have this
position as white and I feel like I have
good chances but I I don't think I'll be
completely confident that I'm gonna win
the game just just by being in this
position where I'm playing for two
results and can try to press for a very
long time it gives you a good feeling
about the position here I I do still
think with the very precise play Black
should be able to hold this position but
it's very unpleasant with that Knight
only five that line I think with the
pawn on G5 you are probably holding it
because it's we have equal material
after all on the board but you do have
to play accurately here but the one
thing we see the advantage that Doula
had on a clock hit about 30 minutes more
earlier it's disappeared now he is
actually behind on the clock and he's
not 100 sure he's not like really
confident whether or not he's actually
that much better anymore
thank you for that bar and let's just
remind our audience that this is the
opening events for the GCT tour as we
have more chess in store right right
after this tournament just in couple
days we have super bad rapid and Blitz
where Magnus Carlson will be joining
how exciting yes and after that in this
in summer in July we'll have super
United rapid and Blitz and then we to
come Stateside for the close of the tour
right with St Louis rapid and Blitz and
sinkhold cup I noticed that the the tour
seems to be getting later in the year uh
December and again joins us for the
super bet as well as a super United
rapid and Blitz
and I think the reason for the um
tweaking of the the world championship
match we absolutely had to accommodate
dingler and nepo
and let's uh jump to Bucharest for the
view from view Bucharest with Christian
while I was just going to push back a
little bit on those variations and give
my own variation and uh why I think Duda
was thinking about this position not
necessarily that he doesn't believe in
his Advantage anymore but just because
he had a huge uh another opportunity but
choice in the position and one of them
as you guys were mentioning is to pick
up the H4 Pawn but I was looking through
the lines and to my eyes at least to my
untrained eyes without an engine Knight
to D2 made a lot of sense uh why am I
saying that because it defends the pawn
on B3 and this is what I think he was
calculating root to B8 obviously or uh
pushing for that Bishop takes B3 and now
E4
um taking advantage of the fact that the
rookon H3 protects on the third rank
that pawn on B3 so now not only that but
once you take on e4 I'm going to uh roll
over to the C3 file the C file on C3
with the rook and now this is a double
attack the bishop has to go to D3 not
only that I can take on C6 and say hey I
have a two connected past pawns how is
this position well the engine actually
says that this position is completely
equal because despite of the fact that
you have uh connected past pawns I have
a lot of um ideas connected to the
weakness of your King on E1 specifically
after King to F6 following it up with
Rook to G8 attacked the pawn on G2 and
that H4 Pawn is so powerful for a black
so this is what Duda was calculating
this is one of the lines that you can
play but also instead of Rook takes C6
F3 was very tempting as well this makes
some room for your king and now after F5
maybe I can start considering ideas of
King to F2 King to E3 from a visual
perspective it looks very good for white
from an objective perspective and
perhaps do that made the right decision
black has a lot of counter play on the G
file a lot of counter play connected
with that H4 Pawn so unfortunately for a
Duda he maybe realized that his
Advantage has slipped a little bit maybe
this was his idea from uh afar right he
was looking at this position seeing two
connected past pawns and thinking that
he has a decisive Advantage as he got
closer to getting this position on the
board he realized that is not that easy
and right now we have that Rook to H4
Rook to G4 still a long way a very
difficult defense for firuja but he's
definitely inching closer and closer to
that equality in the position guys back
to you what do you think of these guys
thank you Christian for that because I
do like the idea of e3 E4 and The Rook
on H3 that wasn't due to his choice by
the way he did capture Rook H4 Bishop
takes B3 on the board now Rook G4 check
King f8 again on the board in evaluation
at least the engines evaluation has
precipitously declined so much so that
is not much in it anymore sorry the
variation that Christian was showing
with E4
keeps both connected passers and there's
something it brings The Rook over to the
queen side it's shocking that black is
still holding in that position I know
and what was it most especially shocking
for me was you reach this position I
think it's very pretty easy to calculate
you get here you start to think about F3
and you go nah give me the pawn I've got
two connected past pawns I I can win the
day uh with that
King F6 like wait a minute like what I
mean and then suddenly there's some very
serious counter play based on Rook G8
and that is a bit of a shock because
when you do get to play E4 and Rook C
for three you're thinking how wonderful
I am it's all going my way I've got
these great ideas for you and then
suddenly Rook cheese too and it's like
wait a minute wait a minute how come
we're not reading on the same hymn book
uh E3 E4 was interesting that did not
happen once again Rook H4 was uh do this
choice we are up to date after King f8
12 more moves before our time control
players have plenty of time and again as
we have it but a single game for those
of you who are joining us late or early
depending on your time zone and where
you might be uh we have four draws in
the history book so far as a number of
games were Grandmaster draws and one I
don't you know Sterling piece of
preparation for both uh Anish and uh
Fabi as four draws Rook h pardon me Rook
G4 to F4 uh just please see the position
that we're discussing with Knight on E5
and White's Pawn all the way to G4 G5
right so let's say we we take uh Knight
E5 yes me the pawn
uh Rook A7 oh excuse me
yeah it's a tricky tricky it's a tricky
Rook F Rook H4 actually sets up
if Bishop A4 white has Knight G5 exactly
yeah Bishop a yes that's what I want I
meant to say that Knight takes E6 as
well as Rook takes F7 is supposed to be
a little bit careful right okay we play
King E7 first okay
so now I'll play 95. You'll Play F6 I'll
go Knight takes H pardon me Knight takes
E6 check King D6 okay just a second I
don't believe this at all but I once had
a uh
a lot of pawns for a bishop against bent
Larson but uh no with the pawn on D5
yeah somehow you will yeah okay it's
possible all right uh the king E7 I
think is an important uh defensive move
bar for black to get in absolutely it's
a crucial move because the way that do
that played he's trying to get this
Knight G5 move in and King E7 will it's
possible it will result into that end
game that we saw where uh White is down
a piece but it's got three pawns uh let
me show you a few more lines uh in that
in that direction here so here after
Rook F4 King E7 the best move
you have two options in this position
you can play 95 and we will reach that
position or we can we can play the move
G4 here
and the idea behind G4 is to try to put
a Pawn on G5 and then get a knight only
five here so let's say Rook takes A4 not
a lot of black play F6 yes yes play the
move G5 and now you're not allowing this
move F6 and here uh
black can play the move Bishop C2
right
and if you
and now you play Rook F6
okay and then with the idea to play 95
so here I think white is still slightly
better here but we go back here there's
another alternative here is the move
Rook A1 check okay King D2
Rook A2 check
King C3 now we're attacking the bishop
and in the same line you put the bishop
on C2 here and Knight E5 move will be
met by Bishop F5 and you are giving up
the pawn on C6 but you have very an easy
pieces your Bishop is well placed here
and you have a active Rook here white is
still a little bit better here but it
should you know black should be able to
hold this should be able to hold this
because the bishop is actually well
placed here the only way you can really
make big progress is to play F3 E4 but
it's going to be very hard to do that I
just give you a check move the king
further away then I have this one rookie
2 and you cannot play the move E4 here
this so this will be a draw immediately
so I think with the accurate play
alireza should hold now the king E7 is
very important and let's check again
that that end game that we were looking
at after
the peace sacrifice here King D6 so here
in this position you have F6 but also
you have the move Knight before
but the problem is you're not going to
be able to consolidate here so Rook
takes A4 attack in the Knight Knight D3
and now you play Bishop C4 okay
attacking the Knight
Knight C5 Knight C5
Rook A1 check King D2 King D2 and I
simply play the move King E7
and now you if you move the Rook away I
have a rook A2 and you have a problem
with the F2 Pawn here so even though you
have an extra Pawn here but you can't
really make much progress in this
position
black is very active Bishop is well
placed on C4 and Rook on A1 if you had a
way to get the rook in then you have
excellent winning chances but your Rook
is kind of tied up to the defensive of
the F2 Pawn so what you're saying is the
pawn doesn't make much of a difference
in that case give me the difference and
I'll take the difference but I
understand what you're saying active
rook in a lot of the cases will save the
day for Ali Reza because that's why in a
lot of Rook end games it's very well
known that even with an extra Pawn it's
a draw because if the weaker side gets
an active Rook they can hold the end
game exactly that activity and in the in
this case the active Rook absolutely but
I'll research just needs to make one
accurate move King E7 and yeah it's
extraordinary how uh you know you could
be playing a very very good game of
chess and just literally blow it with
one move and it's so easy in this
position to look at the move you know
Rook takes uh
Rook takes A4
visualize excuse me without the move
King E7 are you to visualize the night
jumping to E5 where it's a double attack
I mean you look at double attacks first
right and then you go down the Primrose
path so you go Rook takes e495 Rook A7
and you know I that's an end game I'm
prepared to play
so easy to overlook Knight G5 right I
mean we we did it ourselves I mean it
was just that hesitation because
if we lose the E6 Pawn that's spells
real well real trouble like that I mean
I'm thinking that's just actually Doom
so I mean King E7 I mean I hate to
overstate the case but that seems like
the only move actually for Ali rais's
fan and jumping back over to you for
King E7 only move right yes King E7 is
definitely the only move here there is
another move here Rook A7 but I think
it's not as good I will show why for
example if you play Rook A7 here now
white can actually use this Pawn as a
decoy because you can no longer take
because you will run into the same
problem of the move Knight G5 and now we
have a threat of Knight takes C6 and
Rook F7 so that's the reason why Rook A7
is not as good and now in this position
already it's a plus two advantage of wow
for white because if you play Bishop A4
now I play the move Knight E5
putting pressure on F7 and
you play let's say Bishop B5
trying to defend and now just simply G4
if you play passively Just G4 G5 comes
in and it's just going to be very
difficult to defend this F7 so this is
just winning position for white so Rook
A7 is not as good just because of this
idea of A5 you can use this to deflect
The Rook here so only move here the case
King E7 and he's been spending a lot of
time here about uh eight nine eight
minutes here he already spent here and
he really needs to finally Reza needs to
find the smooth King E7 otherwise he
could be in big trouble here
absolutely thank you for that or as we
prepare for our break we just want to
remind our viewers of the results uh
thus far in round eight
had four drops today between nvl DX
thing rapper karua nakiri and nepo again
so very very nice and let's not forget
uh it's all important our audience happy
Mother's Day hello Mommy
and across the world uh Mother's Days
Are celebrated everywhere and Happy
Mother's Day to each and every one of
you
we'll take a break we'll be back soon
[Music]
it's your move the muni premiere of
Chess plays the muni through July 11th
sponsored by St Louis chess club and the
World Chess Hall of Fame for
ticketsmuni.org
chess and St Louis is back with nine
major tournaments throughout the year it
all kicks off in March with the second
edition of the American cup with 16
players across two Fields fighting for a
300 thousand dollar prize fund in this
double elimination tournament with both
classical and Rapid time controls for
the first time since 2020 the Cairns cup
is Back featuring the world's best
female chess players competing for a 180
000 prize fund beginning June 3rd
seasonal Classic Events are back
starting with the spring chess Classic
on April 5th the summer chess classic
August 2nd followed up with the St Louis
Norm Invitational and the winter chess
classic wraps up the year in December
September brings back everyone's
favorite chess night Alex where some of
the world's best don't even know what's
coming and compete for a 150 000 prize
fund 30 players across three Fields come
together in St Louis for the U.S juniors
girls and Senior championships starting
July 15th in partnership with U.S chess
the best in the U.S fight to be the
nation's best and a four hundred
thousand dollar prize fund in October as
the U.S and U.S women's championships
takes place in the chess capital of
America a year full of action-packed
Chess is just getting started all
broadcasts are available on our St Louis
chess club YouTube and twitch.tv
channels
thank you
[Music]
thank you foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back everyone for the super bet
chess classic we are around eight and we
already have four results let's see all
right today we have all draws and one
potentially decisive game still going on
which is so important for our standings
we do not like the way the Ali Reza
farouza is defending this position and
we think Duda could actually win the
game but we just want to take a quick
peek ahead for tomorrow's pairings for
the championship round right in the last
round we have ferrusha playing mvl be
all French class Wesley saw playing Duda
could be a potential first place the
decision in Rockford against Carolina
that's definitely a first place decision
and diac against ding a lot to look
forward to tomorrow but let's just jump
into the current position and we didn't
like this move Rook A7 and we didn't
like the move Bishop A4 and it really
feels like right here right now
there's a chance for Duda to win the
game bar absolutely and he played the
correct move Knight G5 is exactly and
now he's going to take only six and this
is he got the dream position absolutely
dream position very very unpleasant end
game to defend here so let's analyze a
little bit let's analyze a little bit
deeper here to see uh what's the best
way to continue for white
so Knight G5
Bishop A6
Knight takes E6 check and here uh he
played King E7
so white has many options here it's not
easy to
navigate here you have let's say Knight
C5 looks very natural but it's better to
keep the Knight on this side of the
board to try to put pressure here
so Knight G5 is one option to put
pressure on F7
and if you play F6 actually you're
losing this F Pawn after Knight H7 you
cannot to protect you cannot protect the
pawn so you're gonna have to play a more
passive King f8 and in that case we can
try to bring the Knight to E5 and also
try to put the pawn on g-file which is
the desired in many of the variations we
play G4 G5 so to prevent the move F6 so
for example King G7 we go 95
Rook C7 and here actually play King G2
this this would be ideal because now
black is also tied up to the defense two
weaknesses I think this is a technically
winning end game for white okay getting
that Knight on E5 would be absolutely
yeah it makes all the difference in the
world and we think dude is very very
aware as is farugia as far Asia just
looked in disgust because what he might
have missed as we were on our break we
reached this position and what he might
suddenly have realized is that well this
is great I've got everything defended
the pawn is defended all I've got to do
is just move my king so that I don't
lose the E6 Pawn with check until he
might have suddenly realized wait a
minute
oh dear Rook takes Rook takes her Knight
take same uh difference this Pond is
ready uh for uh promotion so that was
why he ended up taking and again trading
off using the a pawn as a decoy to get
rid of this absolutely vital E6 Pawn
makes all the difference in the world
and by the way we do have your
suggestion Knight C5 very I mean anybody
wants to play Knight C5 in my book it's
a strong player you're putting your
knight on a great Outpost it just so
happens that in this specific very
position you can go Pawn hunting yes and
I think if white one Knights if I have
white would actually lose most of the
advantage after Bishop C4 yeah has this
idea to just give you checks on a1a2
right and white cannot manage to get out
of it without giving up a pawn
I think so yes rats rats is how I say
what I say to that Knight G5 F6 on the
board and another inaccuracy I think and
now uh sorry interrupting so after F6
now you're winning the second Pawn after
Knight H7 you said blood have F5 and on
Rook after five Bishop D3 or it doesn't
achieve anything
Knight F7 and we've got a uh
yes takes bishop and check hoping to
keep the knight in the corner oh that is
actually there's a check oh no but
you're right if the Knight were were to
be stranded on H7 but your very next
turn you're ready to go night uh back
and maybe night back and night you do a
little pirouette and again it's two
pawns Knight H7 that looks like the
money move dude I has to play in it yeah
it's a clincher though
and for farouza I mean he climbs back in
the tournament after
pretty harsh loss in the first round and
somehow he says a miracle draw against
and then in this game I was sorry but he
got comprehensively outplayed we could
say that Duda gave him chances of making
a draw but he had no no no winning
chances that is to say farouja had no
winning chances in this game and this is
pretty impressive stuff by Duda up to
this point hadn't scored a win what a
time to win a game right yeah I did it
feels good and he has played F5 and by
the way as we were coming back on break
it was remarkable because it was just
move 31 and you know they're in a deep
into a end game you would think that you
reach this position after move 50 or 60
right not move 31 and time trouble was
still a factor at this point and now we
do have F5 on the board we are expecting
to move Rook takes at five followed by
Rook E5 check which gives you that extra
tempo you need to rescue your wayward
Knight
four moves to time control and how much
time does farucha have left has one
minute and 11 seconds
it's not bad because soon all of his
troubles are going to be behind him
there's nothing to worry about anymore
positions losing Bishop D3 on the board
we're expecting rookie five check
followed by bringing the Knight home
yeah because if white didn't have this
in between move of Q5 here yeah if I had
to play Rook H5 I think after a little
K2 black
still sight in this exactly the the very
very annoying checks and if you can pick
up one Pawn very good chance that the
three versus two that remains uh draw
but this check makes all the difference
in the world
wherever you move your king is actually
six let's say King David six yes yes
okay let's say Knight G5 okay I still go
uh okay we're okay two makes perfect
sense and what I wanted to do Nazi was
actually in a very funny way Defender F2
Pawn in the sense that I want to invite
you to give me check and I've got I have
two Pawn covered but once your Rook does
land on E2 then I've got Knight F4
forking your pieces if you will so
I feel like if I can keep the F2 Pawn
for a moment and I get to play G4 and G5
and then I put my giveaway upon but I'll
use my G Pawn I I should win the game
but it's very important this move rookie
five is just the wonderful you know
accidents that work in your favor
and I know one player in uh the uh Hotel
who is cheering Duda on and that is the
co-leader coming into today's round
Fabiano if I do that does manage to
score a win that would leave I mean
solid yeah go first yes going into the
last round
that's always a very very good feeling
I must say yes he would only need a draw
potentially to at least go into tie
breaks and because Richard is one of
those players who has a half a point
behind him a draw from Bobby's point of
view is fantastic because uh that means
that he's taking care of a pursuer now
keep in mind uh Richie with the white
pieces to Mars having a quiet tournament
but a successful one yes he'll be
looking forward to tomorrow's Clash King
D6 on the board uh bar I've been
suggesting Knight G5 Knight H3 maybe the
engine has something even more potent
instead of the move Knight HD there is
something a little bit stronger here I
will show you uh but I think Knight HD
is still good so in this position you
need to play the move Knight G5 Knight
f8 is also winning but Knight G5 is more
natural you bring the Knight into the
game you're up two pounds it's just a
matter of consolidating the position
right now still the king is a little bit
awkward here only once so Rook A2 needs
to be played and the threat is now is to
play rookie to check you cannot go to
the F1 because Rook takes E3 IDs so what
you need to do in this position is
protect your F2 Pawn here so one idea I
see that it's very clear is to play
rookie 6 check King goes on D7 or C7 and
then you just put the Rook on F6 now you
never have to worry about this f-pawn
hanging and then you can slowly start
advancing the g-pawn in this position
sorry for example rookie to a check King
G1 F2 is guarded if you go back to
A2 the the next thing we need to do here
before we start pushing the G Pawn we
bring this Knight into E5 so we can go
Knight F7
if you go King E7 Rook F4 Rook is very
well placed here now Knight Will land
only five attacking the bishop and only
then we are ready to start to push the G
pawn and this should be a pretty easy
win now yeah that looks really nice the
upper's on 95 and just to remind
everybody we will be starting an hour
early you guys yes tomorrow the last
round starts one hour earlier uh 2 20
p.m Bucharest time and 6 20 a.m Saint
Louis time Central Time see that
Greenwich Mean Time that always throws
me off wait a minute we're in St Louis
and the playoff coverage well if
necessary it will start at 6 30 p.m
Bucharest time and 10 30 Central Time
very very good
four to to tomorrow's Championship round
and we do have rookie two on the board
would you prefer Yasser if we had
playoffs
well speaking as a commentator no
speaking as a chess fan yes yes I I I
you know really I must say the
Armageddon games are really stressful on
the players they feel like you know you
you just gained a year
um yeah I would not recommend it to
other players but it's so fun to watch
you're you're suffering uh but reminding
everybody what the playoff scenario
would look like in case we were to have
one if there's a two-player uh Tai then
we'll have a two-game rapid match with
15 minute time control 10 second
increment if there is three plus players
tied then there will be a rapid round
robin with 10 minute 5 Second increment
time control and if they are still tied
after the rapid games we will have an
Armageddon game five minutes for white
four for black with two second increment
from move 61. bar chime in with your own
uh Armageddon experience uh you love it
uh well I don't know if I love it I had
played in Armageddon a couple of times I
both lost and I won but uh definitely
very very stressful uh one my first
Armageddon I remember was the World Cup
uh World Cup in Russia that I lost this
was like about uh you know 50 almost 15
years ago and then I also in the very
next World Cup I actually won in
Armageddon so it's it's it's very very
stressful and I played a few of them you
know in U.S Championship as well uh it's
just uh you know at that point you're
just you know nerves
stronger nerves and just uh that's going
to be the deciding factor in that
I remember I believe it was a U.S
Women's Championship played here in St
Louis where Anna zatonsky
yeah on a complained to me that she'd
lost it Arena or she blundered a rook
uh it may have been an Armageddon came
it may have been a playoff game she says
she said to me yeah sir how could I do
that how could I blunder The Rook I said
on it has nothing to do with your chest
skills this is nerves this is just
nerves and everybody gets nervous in
these Armageddon games and the the uh
chess is best just as it works by the
way I really liked the you know the
engine suggestion of routing The Rook to
F7 pardon me to F6 why did I say F7
putting the Rook on F6 so that you could
go Knight F7 followed by 95. uh Duda
took a page from my own book and he said
well Knight H3 defends F2 and then I get
my setup which will be winning uh but I
just think that that move Rook on Rook
to E6 followed by Rook F6 more precise
why do I say that because in my heart of
hearts I am allowing C5 and you know
remember it's all about just taking away
all of the options that the opponent has
you see C5 you see the potential for C4
you just say wait a minute why do I
alarm I'm not comfortable with that yeah
I don't I don't like a lot I shouldn't
in this position C5 wouldn't work
because of Knight F4 yeah that's the bad
that's the bad news but when you do go
rookie six check pardon me let me put
that on the board you do play rookie six
check
you're not playing C5 no you're not
getting in C5 that's successful not
successfully The Rook will fight will
will be in all of its Glory Untouchable
on F4 the night will get to E5 your two
bonds up and I think that will be very
very easy night on H3 let's just see
what we've got
well wait a minute wait a minute
C5 so that D5 wouldn't be hanging and
instead of moving The Rook away just to
get right to avoid 35 or H5 of Rook H5
so I can go Rook H6 check but you
haven't made one more move Bishop there
we go Duda played immediately G4 wait a
minute aren't we allowing C5 which is
that in play
if you didn't play
so it is wow if firosha played C5 it was
Black coming back into the game or well
that was a sole chance right to come
back into the game C5 I guess I'm moving
my Rook I mean obviously
by the way if we take a look at the
clock firusha made his last move with
two seconds on the clock are you kidding
and they just made move 40 so we should
have kept an eye on that it could have
been a time travel mistakes that they
both made wow yeah because even though
it's
an end game it was actually the first
time control being completed uh C5 uh
VAR jumped right in uh a chance a chance
C5 was a very very big chance for
alireza and he had to go for it I'm
surprised he didn't just play this
instantly because you know you need to
get some activities create some
weaknesses and this was the the right
time because now Knight F4 is not going
to do much because you can just take on
D4 already and you have some problems
with the F2 Pawn actually I can also
sorry I can also give you a check on A1
here first so he definitely had to play
the move C5 here I will show you on on
my board here so if you play the move C5
now if you move the Knight then you have
problems with the F2 Pawn so neither I
simply give you a check first right you
go up
and check again check again
and uh now again F2 Pawn is saying if
you go back then we have the repetition
here King C3 actually runs into a check
again and so this might be a draw
already because if you go King B2 I have
another check on B1 so C5 was absolutely
necessary to create some control play
and the best continuation now for white
is try to play the move Rook F5
and now uh you have a few options you
can give a couple of checks Rook A1 Rook
A2 another alternative is to play King
C6 and then at some point you want to
make a run here it can be packing before
King C3 because if your king is on City
then you're threatening to give a plan
for a win the king is a little bit stuck
only one it's not easy to see how you're
gonna cross to Safety in this position
so this was another alternative but yeah
he definitely had to play the move C5
and but he didn't he played the check
and now of course uh he just play the
move you don't want to play King F1
because you run into the rookie three
move so that would be a problem oops uh
and now black black actually might be
even better after rookie five so you
just play King D1 and I think this is
just losing now because you don't have
time to stop or if black plays C5 here
let's show the audience what the
difference is yes if you play C5 here
there is a very nice tactic here that
wins the game and that is Rook takes D5
check oh that's a vision tool if you
take with the bishop I just take your
rook and if you take back with the King
simply pork Knight F4 check King E4
Knight takes E2 I'm up a lot of Pawns
here and after the move King F3 actually
the best the best continuation is to
give up the piece because you have four
Pawns in this position now four C Pawn
is going through and uh yeah this is
just going to be a winning end game here
so
let's take a look through the magic of
Television how close did farrugia come
to flagging well counted down uh four
seconds three seconds oh wow better
speed it up
okay that was a little bit slow motion
but it came down to two seconds there
before he completed his move before he
made the big mistake that now allows
white to just push the pawn and I must
say I I am very surprised actually
stunned to see farooja making this many
mistakes and let's be clear there's been
in quite a number of mistakes that
perugia's made missing the king E7 that
whole Rook A7 uh idea getting gifted
gifted an opportunity to play C5 I mean
he could have easily been forced to
resign after rookie six check and Rook
F6 gifted a a chance to play C5 and
instead you know
wow uh just you know some days we just
can't play our best exactly uh that
that's what it seems to be let me just
refresh my board for a moment catch up
with the players because I am seeing a
Pawn on G5 and I was like huh did that
pawn really make it that far and the
answer is yes it did
I think we're about to see a resignation
pretty soon I don't see any counter play
because yeah you have one or two checks
but
C5 comes in but it's too little too late
yeah yeah that pawn is really really it
is so far Advanced so can should white
just push G6 here yes yes just continue
pushing absolutely pushing baby
uh any chances with check and C4 C3
that's
the last Alaska but no no no it's it's
it sounds too slow yeah it's all too
slow and you have your Bishop on the way
so that's why you can't really yes
otherwise C4 would have created some
Contra play here
yeah looking at across the board to see
my opponent's body posture there
faroogia really looks like he's
suffering this this end game that
doesn't look like uh he's particularly
enjoying himself I think firoza knows
that he he had chances that he missed
yeah in this end game even though he was
worse most of the game he definitely had
chances to save the game exactly
remember I was at the dinner once and uh
Sasha grishock
came over to our dinner table and said
yeah sir I was really really impressed
by your posture your body posture at the
end of your game with
um
Judith pogar you are sitting at the
board so calmly with your hands together
and you were just looking and I was
saying why is Yasser so confident okay
he's exchange up but I I didn't
understand it that you were just so
confidently sitting at the board waiting
for her to resign then I realized you
weren't an exchange you were an exchange
in a rook up and you were really really
confident and now I understood it yeah
uh yeah you didn't have the confidence
it doesn't look supremely confident even
though he's two pawns out yeah yesterday
have you ever faked confidence at the
board oh gosh yes I once made uh hold on
it was a combination
where I was better and I was convinced
that this combination the sacrifice was
winning
I made it press the clock and as I was
writing down my move it suddenly
occurred to me that there was a defense
in the position that I hadn't seen when
I made my moves I bluffed
so I put my hands together put in a
stretched and
waited for my father
blocked at the board bar have you
blufted the board
um I might have but I can't recall right
now right now I just played so many
games but yeah yeah it's it's uh
definitely yeah it's it's interesting uh
uh Gary especially very emotional during
his games right he when he made a
mistake so
and also for hikara as well and when he
makes a mistake you see a lot of head
shaking and you don't see the poker face
well Hikaru is actually hard to read
sometimes he's shaking his head when
he's winning yeah yeah all right yeah
it's the opposite for him it means he's
doing well we we almost say you know
there's a
um
it's uh the temple in Yogyakarta uh for
Buddha there's 10 000 Buddha statues on
this Temple so the ten thousand faces of
Buddha and we say about Hikaru Nakamura
the Thousand Faces every car in Nakamura
because he's got all of these twisted uh
things uh we do have G5 G6 on the board
as this past Pawn is running for a
touchdown explain this on the board yet
oh it isn't is it or it's our analysis
it's our now I apologize I was about to
say explain to our audience why the move
uh
excuse me I'm just refreshing the board
why is G6 so powerful of our uh the main
reason you just want to advance and get
a Quinn there you go
and further you push stronger they get
right there you go yeah you just want to
advance yes
so that's why he earns the big bucks you
know he gets hired by the club to come
and you know like explain everything
yeah but you're right I mean the pawn
advancing uh closer to Corn coordination
and here in particular we see that the
king is cut off so you cannot really
cross to protect and stop this pawn and
also the bishop is actually on C4 he's
not doing anything to prevent that pawn
from queening so the only piece is to
stop that pond from cleaning is The Rook
but once you play the move Rook A8 I
don't need to play G7 right away I can
just now continue pushing my F Pawn and
just to join my other pawn and play the
move F5 so to and then they continue to
advance together so you never want to
separate the pawns too much because then
you have to use a piece to defend that
advanced pass Pawn keeping it as basic
as possible what's stronger than a pass
Pawn
I really don't see what he's worried
about and sometimes you take your time
to make that final win and move to make
sure you're not missing anything
actually there's one line here guys
maybe we should check this here so there
is this move Bishop B3 check
Bishop B3 check
King E1 King uh yeah King E1 running
away from The Rook of Bishop C4 so if
it's your turn I understand you want to
play C3 and Rook check yep yeah so but
it looks like we just continue G7 give
me a girl
and now C3
queen queen and the King actually
escapes okay one check
King E2 King E2 and if Bishop D1 you
have to play the only move King D3
because if you go to the back rank
you're actually gonna get mated that's a
bit embarrassing so so you have that
kind of tree and you're just winning and
if I give you a check again
excuse me so let me move this up so
anyway check here
and Bishop C4 you're escaping on the F3
F3 Square so right
so this is the only line I think he
needs to calculate I think this would be
winning even if black spawn was on C2
and he would get to promote on the next
move
uh will Checkmate Black's King I
couldn't agree with you more on that uh
so what's behind two Tempe which is yeah
huge yeah it's not even uh it's not not
much of a race actually when you put it
like that
but uh it's also
worth pointing out that if Duda for some
reason doesn't push G6 then it might not
be that winning is it because you know I
I'm thinking what could he be thinking
about he did eventually play G6 the only
other move that comes to my mind is he
could potentially be thinking about
playing King C1 I don't know exactly why
this move would be attractive in any
case he did fall back and maybe it's
just one of those things
he hasn't had it back he has not had a
good tournament this is by far the best
position he's had in the whole
tournament
sitting back and enjoying it a little
bit you know like don't rush me let me
just actually enjoy what is uh the
preceding going on here G6 and as was
mentioned by VAR if we drop back with
the Rook just to stop this fellow from
going too far well F4 and F5 and two
connected past pawns uh I don't think
Ali if you play a move like Rook A8 I
think that's essentially a resignation
kind of move accepting that it's it it's
really really really bad so I don't
expect Rook A8 on the other hand
not even not easy to make a suggestion
right and he's played Bishop B3 check
he's probably going for that C4 line
King E1 is almost a
guaranteed certainty yeah
King C1 guys
loses yeah King C1 loses C4 C3 walks
right into the Checkmate oh boy that
that is quite the pattern isn't it C4 C3
and Rook A1 mate
talk about snatching defeat from the
jaws of Victory just at the finish line
I I mean you know you know the howler
right you know the move is so bad that
uh your cries can be heard in the next
County I mean if In This Moment Bishop
B3 check if
if uh Duda were to play Rook C1 Bobby
screams disguise could be heard you know
you would hear it all the way yeah all
the way here uh it'd be reverberating
through the Bucharest Hotel
yeah
yeah wow this will be a devastating loss
for Fury as he was looking to
possibly going to playoffs tomorrow
absolutely and he would have white
pieces in the last round he might
even have gone for Seoul you know
winning the tournament exactly
so Bishop B3 check King E1 and
maybe one more move of C4 can you on
plate G7 and then it will be a time for
the handshake
I will not feel so badly about his
tournament anymore no these Championship
rounds these penultimate Championship
round as well as the very very last
round of the tournament you win one of
those two games and I don't care how
terrible your result you're having
you feel a little bit better you know
first of all any win at this level this
exalted level is to be celebrated
celebrated absolutely celebrated uh but
uh yeah to be one of the highest rated
players in the world the defending
grantchester Champion you bet Duda will
say well it's not my finest hour but
it's not my worst hour either and I also
I did I didn't choose the most ambitious
opening with the exchange's love no he
basically he was trying to keep
farugia's attacking chances as limited
as possible that game that dioc lost to
farugia in the sloth defense where deact
kept a lot of pieces on the board
doubtlessly made a very strong
impression on Duda and he said you know
let's let's
get a much clearer position without so
much chaos yeah without so many pieces
on the board and this is a strategy that
paid off uh of our uh
it's not maybe for the spectators the
most spectacular but it was effective
today absolutely and I I feel like maybe
alireza wasn't as familiar with opening
ideas there were a few moments where he
had this move G4 that we were analyzing
to stop that night from coming in and I
don't recall seeing him to play this
live exchange positions too often in
fact white usually avoids it but uh
uh if he wanted just to make a draw that
uh the the that game uh played between
kramnik Anand is usually black holds
that position exactly and that opposite
color end game so but I I think firosha
also was trying to get some chances
today as well
sometimes when you're black and you're
you you avoid your skew uh A variation
that you know is drawing because you
want to play
well you may end up playing a bad
position by the way we do have some more
moves let me just update
that seems kind of helpful that last
check in particular let's go to F3 yeah
you dance away from both the rook and
the bishop that means that there's no
counter play against whites King in the
meanwhile this guy
I mean becoming a queen exactly it's a
coronation going on over here so I'm
seeing king of three and I'm not really
seeing why furusia wouldn't resign I
mean it's just yeah this king of Threes
there is there some tricky just just
completely winning exactly is King F1
also in him a natural looking move but
I'm just curious if it's still in it I
think so too right I mean you're just
again you're dancing away from the rook
and Bishop yes King F1 is winning as
well yeah
g700
and he was playing so well right up in
the day look at that forget about round
one just look around to you plus three
Sublime okay by the way he did get lucky
come on against Bobby they could have
been one more donut in there but not a
bad line score right until today where
he was playing against a player who have
not been successful and maybe he came
into the today's game thinking you're
playing poorly or unsuccessfully I'm
playing successfully
um the script I'm reading is I win and
you lose
do this that's a very nice script I
don't wanna I don't want to play ball I
mean I won't play the role that you've
given me of Patsy I will uh trying to
press with the black pieces it's always
very risky it at this levels you bet it
is yeah
yeah and I think today is taking his
time to
just make sure there is nothing no
tricks left in the position
even I can tell you that the world
champions uh Gary Kasparov he wanted to
win with white black green red whatever
the pieces was eyes did Bobby Fischer
and they played grunfeld defenses and
King's Indian defenses uh defenses that
today have a reputation of
incredibly high risk and good chances
that black will lose a number of those
variations of the groomfeld and King's
Indian defenses today you know you
playing for a win with black really is a
danger yeah I think there are very few
top players who play those re
quote-unquote risky opening Screven
King's Indian when mvl comes to mind MBL
nepo used to play the grunfels a lot now
he's kind of Switched Gambit
C4
okay and
G7 or maybe even rookie 8 is better just
so I don't let your
uh come back to the eighth rank
so rookie eight here rookie eight uh
certainly looks nice
yeah okay it is the best tool guys
because you're forcing the Mover K7 yeah
then after that it's a very a very nice
Rook d8 check
first uh even a nice in-between move
yeah yes if you go to E6 then you run
into the move Knight F4 check and uh if
you go to C7 then I have G7 so you have
to clicking so then one more check now
on C8
right yeah
you can go to the seventh rank you have
to stay on the sixth Rank and after that
uh yeah Kings is yeah
seven mm-hmm
it's a girl and uh after oxy checking
the sixth then only then you play the
move Knight F4 and you have prevented
this Pawn from advancing the C Pawn the
only Contra play and uh
yeah just Rook G7 here for example King
G4 King G5 and King F6 very
straightforward win for white absolutely
wow and by the way what's your engine I
am having trouble reading your engine
but it seems to be going uh Hog Wild
yeah mine shows about plus seven almost
here wow on a stronger engine it's like
plus 10 plus 10 even okay so that means
why it's going to get that Queen yes
yes the the the computer doesn't see
checkmate
but not yet
but I can't do that does not have that
body uh posture see in these moments
Gary Kasparov when he's got the uh he he
usually took off his watch and he put it
on the score sheet he took off his
jacket at this point he'd be putting his
watch back on he'd be putting his jacket
back on and he'd be saying okay time for
dinner let's go you know let's sign the
score sheets he'd be letting you know
that your time in the sun is over you're
a busted get out of here yeah who does
not do that not so excited at the same
high degree of confidence as he does
play the powerful Rook E8 stopping
prepping G7 G8 and prepping this line
that we've just seen that continues with
Rook d8 check I think it's just
different personalities you know yeah
yes two days maybe he's always calm
whether he's winning or losing he's
always common collected meanwhile when
you think about Gary of you can read
what's going on oh yeah oh no question
about that yeah how about you at the
board uh no see you you got the game one
I mean you're you're supremely confident
you're looking at your opponent and go
come on come on come on I've never done
that made me feel a little bit
disrespectful it is of course it is so
I'm like dude I'm just very calm and
collected you can't read on my face
what's going on until hands are shaken I
don't smile or look like I'm winning
my uh My Philosophy there is not about
the hands of being shaken it's about the
score sheet being inside and tell this
person the game's not over right bar
absolutely yeah so many times I relax in
a winning position thinking it's already
over and then make one mistake let that
opponent get back into the game you
really have to wait for that resignation
score should sign then to feel like okay
now I can take a little break
played very precise by Duda exactly just
that extra little and believe me when
you're playing these 2 800 guys you
don't give them a single window of
opportunity to escape because they can
find it so your play Precision chess uh
right to the very end this extra little
move whether it's necessary or not is
not the point uh it's just the best move
Grandmaster touch yes the grand masterly
touch Rook d a check again uh the King
goes to E7 that interferes with the
control that black has of the G7 Square
so anytime the king steps back whether
to B2 E7 or even to C7 we're just going
to play G7 you're welcome to munch my
Rook but you're not going to be happy at
the resulting position of Queen
versus The Rook so check you'll go back
check now I've managed to put my Rook
behind the past Pawn with a gain of time
giving me Knight F4 and Alice Gort this
Pawn
their resigns
wow I must say for the defending Grand
Chester champion this has been a
topsy-turvy event starting with a loss
and a second loss today you would think
that maybe Ali Reza would be in some
kind of tank no he's still tied for
second
huh wow he's still tied for a second
yeah he'll have plus one going into last
round game I know he feels Dreadful
exactly at this point but whenever
you're playing for first you've got to
pull yourself together and keep
reminding like yourself you know if I
win tomorrow I could be first if I went
tomorrow I could be first yeah you know
that's what he's got to remind himself
as he's very disappointed with this
result bar but hey give dude that credit
yes dude I played a good game here and
he took advantage of the inaccuracies
that alireza made and there was some
chances at the end for him as well but
he missed that move 40th once again we
see it's a critical moment where if he
had played the move C5 instead of Rook
A2 he would have chances but he played
rookie to check and that is just losing
so good game by Duda and alireza now in
a must win situation in the last game to
try to catch Fabi if he makes a drop
exactly and because it's a to to try the
type of first why is he in a must-win
situation because Bobby is actually
playing somebody in second place Richie
yes so if Richie wins Richie's gonna
have plus two somebody's going to have
plus two and potentially plus three
should Fabi win right oh yes so uh
basically that means if you're in
alireza shoes your only chance of
playing for first is to win with white
in the last round it's been asked and
asked before and a lot of people have
been able to positively answer that and
come back with a win but
anything can happen tomorrow it feels it
you know something about this event
Bobby would disagree with that exactly
but it feels like anything can happen
there's still lots of potential for a
lot of things we still have our Niche
too guys we still have an issue with the
white pieces and playing Nepal who is
also just not playing vulnerable cannot
wait to finish this tournament so
exactly I think Anish definitely has a
good chance tomorrow as well try to put
some pressure
and don't forget that Wesley so even
though Wesley has had some very strange
moments in this tournament he's still
looking at plus one yeah somehow we
forgot about the West you know Wesley's
in the mix too I mean come on in fact
half the players in the fields seem to
be in the mix and here's our round nine
Championship pairings coming up tomorrow
all right we have Fairuza playing MBL
the all French
South plain Duda giri against Napa
report against caruana that's the big
one for all the marbles and diak against
dink that game Wesley so dude look at
that the score suddenly looked a lot
tighter don't they perugia's having to
take down this countrymen nvl uh only
chance for farugia but hey once more the
standings going into tomorrow's
Championship round all right let's take
a look we have copy leading with half
point
in first place and then with four and a
half four players trying to catch him
and Richard report again being one of
the his opponent for tomorrow right and
Fairuza Wesley and Anish as well and
with 50 we have mvl and Duda and in the
last three places sharing yeah
and be a little disappointed maybe that
he couldn't be at that four and a half
that would make the game with Ali raises
so much more exciting as we're just
standing by uh to get the take from
duda's point of view uh
and once again this is what tomorrow
looks like
a little reminder that tomorrow games
start 1 early
so live coverage will start at 2 20 PM
Bucharest time and 6 20 a.m central time
and if necessary we will have playoffs
starting at 6 30 p.m Bucharest time and
10 30 a.m Central Time
nice uh
well uh four draws but we weren't
disappointed uh with the outcome of this
round as this was a huge result bar
absolutely huge result and uh in my
favorite slav exchange opening so of all
things yeah it gives you some ideas to
continue maybe analyzing this opening
there's still potentially if you know
you can beat uh
in this opening so it's uh there's still
some potential definitely with a little
bit of a quiet start couple of early
draws but Fabi game was very interesting
and again once again great work over the
board for Anish giri not being afraid to
go for the complications and analyze
everything and just make an easy draw
with the black pieces and do that win is
a really big win for him and now Wesley
is also a little bit disciplined because
now he's facing somebody who just won a
game and definitely feeling more
confident I'm excited and looking
forward for the last round exactly where
so many things can happen and who will
be our winner well we just ourselves
who would be the winner and I am very
very pleased to say that half of us have
got it right
uh oh I was sure that Tom would be ready
without career predictions just uh I
mean you know darush and Christian we
are proud of you we really really are uh
you have learned what we have taught for
years exactly exactly
um
congratulations your pick was a lot
better you're doing better than us yeah
yeah yeah you sure did I'll take it wow
uh no uh seriously whenever you're
looking at an event it's my first time
so right I'm fine you got that going for
you but uh whenever you get an event
where the world champion and his
Challenger
our ninth position eighth and Ninth you
know the tournament's uh enormously
strong and uh yeah the the the the
energy zap from the world championship
match has been clearly showing yeah it
truly has as we are expecting Bucharest
but we haven't got the word yet
uh that we were going to go over so do
we have any predictions for tomorrow
what do you guys think we're going to
see
well I would say that um
it's going to be a very long Niche yeah
yeah I would say so for for for me
I dreamed of becoming a chess
Grandmaster and bent Larson rather boxed
my ears and said yes or that's
ridiculous stop stop stop stop thinking
about becoming a grand master you're
strong enough You're a Grand Master what
you have to be thinking about is winning
tournaments
so later in my life as I became a
candidate Grand Master I began to
understand yes that is what it's all
about is winning the tournament so I
live for those moments where in the
penultimate round and in the last round
if I had a chance for playing for first
it was like forget everything else that
doesn't matter right now today this
moment Focus if I can win first
you know that's it that's what my career
is all about playing for first so I
think even though Anish has this
reputation of being super super super
super solid and draw and safety and all
of that stuff no no and it's heart of
hearts like all Grandmasters it's about
playing four and winning first and you
know yourself as competitors you're
playing these U.S championships and if
you're in a final round of our I don't
care I don't care who your opponent is
Abby's sitting across the board and you
can play for first you feel like you
should
give it your your your your your your
best and with either with either color
with either color I absolutely agree
with you Yasser it's good to be in a
situation where you actually control
your destiny if you can win your game
and tie a force the tie break like for
example for a report tomorrow if he wins
the game he's gonna guarantee uh he's
gonna guarantee himself uh a playoff so
it's uh and also in some scenarios you
might actually even I think win the
tournament if the other players with
plus one make a draw so he's playing
with the white pieces and I expect to
see something maybe a little bit obscure
to avoid the Fabiano's preparation his
preparation has been excellent with
black and white new ideas looks like he
worked really hard with his team for
this tournament so I expect to see
something unusual tomorrow from report
try to get a position maybe that Fabiano
is not very familiar with yeah and sorry
let me just correct myself I meant to
say Richie not a niche I had the game of
a niche also a try yeah but I I really
think that Richie is sitting there
across the board I'm white I can play
for and win first I have to do
everything and as we uh still uh get
ready for uh Bucharest let's remind
everybody of upcoming events of the
grand chess tour as world number one
Magnus Carlson he's joining the grand
Chester for super better rapid and Blitz
in Poland and also for super United
rapid and Blitz in Croatia yes July 3rd
is the 10th the Magnus will be in both
of those events before we turn Stateside
right and then we'll have in November
and December St Louis rapid and Blitz
and sink World Cup and remember the
grand chess tour players are the one the
Perpetual players if you will are the
ones that pick up those grand chess tour
points so even though Magnus will be
playing in two of the events he won't be
eligible to win the grand chess tour
because he's not playing obviously in
Bucharest and the singfeld
but it's going to be so interesting to
see Magnus play
all these players in Rapid and Blitz
exactly because at the moment I believe
he's still the highest rated player of
course in Rapid Blitz and classical yes
and uh yeah we'll see how these guys can
handle Magnus well for me it's
remarkable that he could be a Triple
Crown winner and be a world champion in
all of these forms because there are
Specialists I mean when I was growing up
there were players who were Blitz
Specialists who are incredibly good at
five minutes and you know to be good at
all the forms that's uh that's amazing
we have some challenges getting set up
in Bucharest as we're anxious to get do
this but uh once more this is it Richie
Rapport versus Bobby not Anish Gary
versus Favi but Richard report and the
ever invented ever creative Richie's
gonna come up with something I'm going
to guess that all the white players
firoza Wesley gerion rapper who have
first place to play for yeah and they
have white pieces we'll be playing for a
win tomorrow absolutely absolutely and
for nepo this is such bad news you know
because you kind of gave up with the
white pieces today he would love to have
a repeat of yeah you would love to have
a repeat of today's game that is to say
neposite can say goodbye to the
tournament put it behind and get on the
next one but Anish Gary is not going to
overlook an opportunity here so of
course do his best
how do you handle last rounds because it
can be pretty tough when you're playing
for the first place you feel the
pressure right you have one game left
but too much is riding on that yeah for
me I'm motivated by first place I the
the scary thing for me is I'm not doing
that great if I'm saying nepo shoes uh
just
there's a there's a desire to get over
the tournament so you don't really put
yeah you don't put your heart and soul
behind it and that could give you you
know you could and you get into trouble
from the opening and it all goes wrongly
so you have to be very aware of that but
uh last rounds weren't my problem my
biggest problem
was so many of my tournaments were
overseas my biggest problem was around
one two and three because I was
overcoming jet lag yeah oh that's where
oh those were brutal brutal brutal days
I think that's why we see a lot of times
players arrive a few days early and
let's go to Bucharest we've been we've
been doing our best with our song and
dance Christian
over to you
thanks yes first of all welcome back to
the studio congratulations a big victory
against one of the co-leaders of the
event going into today's round your
initial feelings after this victory yeah
thank you it's of course very nice uh
feeling uh between the first game like
in here in classical choice but
um yeah it's kind of unexpected because
um
for the round I was feeling quite bad
and actually decided to wrap it up but I
opened it ambitious and I find the thing
in the opening or after the opening and
yeah and I got better position so so
that's quite interesting you say that
because you chose the exchange love and
I thought that that was just a strategy
to try to get him into sort of type of
play that he doesn't feel comfortable in
yeah
yeah I mean I mean yeah it could be this
way normally it would be but um yeah but
yeah today I said I um yeah I was being
kind of kind of butt sick and even had
an up before the game which is kind of
you know extraordinary for me so now I
think this queen B3 Ryan should be five
it's a career in intention I mean
indication one over here and of course
of course here Rook C8 is my move like
it's known since like Stone Age like 594
and
Knight X G4 Bishop takes
g47 and here we need fiber potency fine
he was I apologize for that but we've
lost our feed uh Bucharest some
technical difficulties I was having
trouble with the audio but what what Yan
was basically saying was that he had
been expecting this line and instead of
Knight E4 he was showing uh some of the
prep that he was making in the main main
variation of Rook C8 he said that this
has been known since Stone Age
a little verbally going on there but I
do remember the game I was calling the
action in Bonn in 2008 between Vladimir
kramnik who was on the white side of
this position against fishy and I think
you were showing VAR that Rook C8 had
become the main go-to move because in
those positions at your Pawn up blacks
activity Bishops of opposite uh position
was drawn and unfortunately we are not
going to get the feed but I think maybe
uh somehow we'll upload this interview
when it's all going well uh VAR final
thoughts as uh the championship
everything to be decided tomorrow
absolutely very exciting last round is
awaiting and we have many players who
are still in contention for the first
place and especially players who are
half a point behind Fabiano have the
white pieces they're gonna try very very
hard to win and in particular reach a
report he controls his Destiny if he can
win one game with the white pieces last
game against Fabiano he will guarantee
himself tie for first or with a very
good scenario maybe even clear first
place in this tournament so I'm looking
forward to see the exciting action
tomorrow guys
she will ask the ingleren to be his
trainer for tomorrow's Dave as so much
could be decided on the outcome of that
now see it was really really wonderful
to be here with you
calling the action we've certainly been
having fun tell your friends everybody
where you've been hanging out join us
tomorrow one hour early and once again
happy Mother's Day to all the mothers
out there thank you see you tomorrow and
see you tomorrow
[Music]
thank you
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited